GOOD MORNING WILL BEGIN THAT
SIMPLY BUDGET.
SUB COMMANDER TWO ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY DISGUSTINGLY PROP
NINETY EIGHT DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION THE GOVERNOR'S.
MAY REVISED BUDGET PROPOSALS.
WILL BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE.
AN OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROP NINETY EIGHT.
K. TWELVE AN EARLY EDUCATION
PLAN
.
I DON'T KNOW.
NNOVA.
START WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
MORNINGSTAR ABOUT
AND YOU'RE RECEIVING A HAND.
THE.
SO I THE HAND THAT YOU'LL BE
RECEIVING A COVERS THE.
.
CHANGES THE AND THE GOVERNORS
THAT THE PROPOSAL SINCE JANUARY
OF THE MAY REVISION FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
SO I'M IN FIGURE ONE ON ONE SIDE
OF YOUR SHEET AS ALL OF THE
CHANGES FOR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT IN THE THREE FISCAL YEARS
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SO RELATIVE OUT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUT A. BUDGET REVENUE
INCREASES HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD.
FOR THE THREE YEAR PERIOD THAT
INCREASE IN REVENUES BEEN SEVEN
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND THREE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO AS WE
DISCUSSED ON AT A PREVIOUS
HEARING IN THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN REVENUE DID NOT
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE. TO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
GUARANTEE. THE PRIMARY REASON
THERE SEVERAL FACTORS INVOLVED
BUT THE PRIMARY REASON IS THAT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS A TEST TO
YEAR. AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TURNS PROTESTS THREE YEAR TO
ATTEST TO YEAR WITH THE MAY
REVISION FACTORS. AND UNDER
ATTEST TO YEAR.
THE GROWTH IN THE GUARANTEE IS
DRIVEN BY PER CAPITA PERSONAL
INCOME AND THAT DOESN'T ADJUST
WITH CHANGES IN STATE REVENUE.
SO THE ONLY ADDITIONAL AYE
INCREASE THAT YOU WOULD SEE IN A
TEST TO YEAR AS A RESULT OF
CHANGES IN REVENUE. IS FROM THE
MAINTENANCE FACTOR PAYMENT AND
GENERALLY IF REVENUES GO UP
THERE'S USUALLY A LARGER
MAINTENANCE FACTOR PAYMENT THAT
WOULD BE MADE ON TOP OF IT HAS
TO. HOWEVER IN A THIS FORECAST
WERE COMPLETELY PAIN THE
MAINTENANCE FACTOR BALANCE OFF
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. SO ANY
INCREASES IN REVENUE AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WILL NO LONGER RESULT
IN AN INCREASE THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE REASONING
BEHIND THAT.
SO FOR US SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
MEN ON GUARANTEE IS GOING UP TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. ON AND SIT SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN FOUR HUNDRED SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THE PERIOD SO THAT'S A
TOTAL OF THREE YEAR PERIOD OF
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO ADDITIONALLY WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN THE CITY ADMINISTRATION OF
DONNA ISN'T AND THAT'S PROPOSAL
IS WE'VE ALSO REVENGE THE
GUARANTEE. TO INCLUDE A CHILD
CARE WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT
WERE ADDED TO THE GUARANTEE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OUT
IN THE AMOUNT OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE. POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SO PART OF THE INCREASE
YOUR SCENE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION A LARGE
PORTION OF IT IS ACTUALLY FROM
THE RETENTION AND NOT
NECESSARILY THE CHANGES IN THE
FACTORS.
SO WHILE IT DOES SEEM THAT THE
FORECAST IS. NOT WHAT WE'RE
ACCUSTOMED TO IN TOTAL
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
GROWING SIGNIFICANTLY YEAR OVER
YEAR OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE WHICH AND
SAT. SEVENTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IT'S A NINE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE OVER
THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD SO THERE
IS STILL SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN
THE GUARANTEE. JUST NOT WITH THE
NEW REVENUES.
SO IN FIGURE TWO.
IT IS A LIST OF ALL THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES THAT.
ARE NEW AND THEN OF SOME THAT
EXIST IN SUCH AS YOU BOTH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND MAY
REVISION SO IN TOTAL WITH THE
CHANGES IN THE GUARANTEE.
A SUBTLE AT PAYMENTS AND OTHER
ONE TIME SAVINGS AVAILABLE WITH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT THERE'S
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF
AVAILABLE RESOURCES PUTTING THE
TOTAL FOR THE THREE YEAR PERIOD.
AT SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION.
SO BEFORE.
I MOVE ON TO THE SPENDING PLAN
THAT'S ON THE OTHER SIDE I'D
LIKE TO WALK YOU THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. UP FOR
CERTIFYING THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
AS OUTLINED IN A YOUR FIGURE
THREE ON THIS PAGE. AT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING A
NEW CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
IT'S PROCESS WOULD BE DONE
ANNUALLY. IT WILL PROVIDE
CERTAINTY AROUND FUTURE
SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS AND WILL
ALSO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THIS WHOLE
PROCESS.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP LIKE RESOLVE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
AND THAT KINDA GET STRUNG OUT
THROUGH THE YEARS BECAUSE WE BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS INTERPRETATION
DIFFERENCES IN AND DIFFERENT
VALUES IMMEDIATELY.
THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS WOULD
BEGAN AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
WOULD GO ALL THE WAY BACK TO
CERTIFY IN YEARS FIVE STARTING
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN. SO
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE I SHOULD BE CERTIFIED
NINE MONTHS OUT OF AFTER THE
CLOSE OF THE FISCAL YEAR. SO THE
TIMELINE THAT SIN LA RIGHT NOW
IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BECAUSE
SOME OF THE FACTORS ARE ACTUALLY
NOT FINAL. UNTIL IT WOULD BE
THIS MAY REVISION PROCESS.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN OVER THOUGH.
SEVERAL YEARS SOME
INTERPRETATION LIKE HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER DIFFERENCES
AND HOW THE LAWS INTERPRETED SO
BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE NOT
SERVED BY THE GUARANTEE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE.
SO THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON
RETIRING DEBTS AND LIABILITIES
AND THEN JUST THROWING UP ANY
OBLIGATION IT'S OH TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS WE MOVE. TOWARD A
NEW ADMINISTRATION COMING IN.
SO UNDER THIS NEW PROCESS I EACH
YEAR AT THIS TIME BID FINANCE
WOULD PUBLISH A CERTIFICATION
VALUE FOR THE PRIOR FISCAL YEAR
SO IF WE WERE DOING THIS
CURRENTLY THE FISCAL YEAR WE
WOULD BE CERTIFYING RIGHT NOW
WOULD BE THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AMOUNT. THAT AMOUNT WOULD BE
POSTED I'M AND PUBLISHED.
AND THEN.
AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND RESPONSES
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
IT WOULD INVOLVE OF THAT THE
PART OF THE.
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THE.
S. P. AYE THIS
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION.
BLINK DOT NOT.
AND THEY WOULD PROVIDE THE DATA
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THEY
ALREADY PROVIDE US WITH FOR THIS
THEY WOULD GIVE US THEIR AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE THE F. T.*.
ALSO ANY ALLOCATIONS AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN PROPERTY
TAXES
AND THEN FINANCE WOULD USE ALL
OF THEIR UPDATED FACTORS THAT WE
HAVE AT THIS POINT IN TIME IN
MAY REVISION. TO CALCULATE THE
FINAL MINIMUM GUARANTEE FOR
CERTIFICATION PURPOSES ONCE
THAT'S POSTED FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME AND WE HAVE FUN.
A CHANCE TO RECEIVE RESPONSES
AND COMMENTS BACK THEN. A JUNE
THIRTIETH THE FINAL
CERTIFICATION AMOUNT WOULD BE
POSTED AND THAT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE RESPONSES ALL OF THE
INPUT AND COMMENTS THAT RECEIVED
WITH RESPONSES AND ANSWERS TO
ANY QUESTIONS.
SO AFTER.
.
JUNE THIRTIETH THERE WOULD BE A
NINETY DAY PERIOD KINDA WAITING
PERIOD SOTHAT ANYONE WHO WOULD
WANT TO FILE A LEGAL CHALLENGE
COULD DO SO.
AND IT THE IN ABOUT THIRTY DAYS
IF NO LEGAL CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
FILED THEN THE CERTIFICATION
WOULD BE FINALIZED I'M AT THAT
POINT IN TIME ANY SETTLE UP
OWED.
OR ADJUSTMENTS WOULD BE MADE.
.
GOING FORWARD. SO ALSO IS PART
OF THIS UP PROPOSAL THERE IS
THE.
CREATION OF A PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT ALLOCATION SCHEDULE.
THIS MECCA THIS MECHANISM ALLOWS
FOR ADDED BUDGET FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE OF IN THE STATE
AND ALSO SORT ALLOWS YOU TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO APPROPRIATION
THAT COUNT TOWARDS MEETING THE
MOMENT GUARANTEE. WITHOUT
ACTUALLY REDUCING APPROPRIATIONS
ONGOING OR ONGOING ALLOCATIONS
TO SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE IF WE WOULD
BE FINALIZING THE PRIOR YEAR
RIGHT NOW AND IT WAS DETERMINED
THAT THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
WHICH TO MANY APPROPRIATIONS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THAT
FISCAL YEAR WERE CERTIFYING THAN
THAT AMOUNT OVER THAT EXCEEDS
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE CREDITED TO THIS
COST ALLOCATION ACCOUNT.
AND HAT CREDIT WOULD BE USED IN
FUTURE TIMES WHEN WE OWE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS
SUBTLE UP OR WE OWE THEM
ADDITIONAL APPROPRIATION.
SO IN YEARS THAT WE DID ARE
CERTIFIED THE GUARANTEE.
AND IT'S DETERMINED THAT THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH THAT'S BEEN
APPROPRIATED THEN AFTER THE
FINAL CERTIFICATION THE
CONTROLLER WORD AUTOMATICALLY
APPROPRIATE. THOUGHT SATELLITE
BALANCE.
FIRST THOUGH THEY WOULD PLAY ANY
CREDIT IN THIS A COST ALLOCATION
SCHEDULED TO FIX
EXTENT THAT IT COVERS THAT IN
ANYTHING THAT IT DOESN'T COVER
WOULD BE APPROPRIATED. IF THE
STATE COULDN'T AFFORD TO MAKE
THE FULL PAYMENT THAT POINT IN
TIME. THAN A MULTI YEAR PAYMENT
AGREEMENT WOULD BE OUT IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND THE
CONTROLLER WOULD APPROPRIATE
TOWARD THAT SCHEDULE SO PROVIDES
MORE CERTAINTY AND MANY
SATELLITE PAYMENTS.
IN SOME OF OUR SETTLED POUNCES
RIGHT NOW DATE BACK TO NINE TEN.
THERE IS A CAP.
ON THE COST ALLOCATION SCHEDULE
OF ONE PERCENT
SO THIS DOES PUT WHAT GOD DOES
LIMIT THE FLEXIBILITY OF THIS
COST ALLOCATION BUT IT ALSO.
ALLOWS IT TO NOT GROW AS LARGE.
OR TWO LARGE THAT IT'S BECOMES
UNWIELDY.
SO ALSO AS PART OF THE.
.
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
THERE'S A PROPOSAL TO MAKE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
I'M CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED.
RIGHT NOW IN CURRENT LAW LCF
FAST
THE BASIS CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED HOWEVER THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT IS PROVIDED IS
DISCRETIONARY.
SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO IT
WOULDN'T IT WOULD MIMIC THE
REVENUE LIMITS OF THE PAST
AND PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I'M.
AND AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
ADDITIONAL. ASSURANCES THAT CALL
IT WOULD BE PROVIDED.
SO AND FINALLY I MIGHT MENTION
IT EARLIER BUT IT IS PART OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS THE RETENTION
OF THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE TO
INCLUDE THE CHARA THAT CHILD
CARE. WRAPAROUND THAT. IS
AT THE BACK TO FIFTEEN SIXTEEN.
THE WITHOUT AM I'LL GO DOWN INTO
THE CAGE IS THE CAPABLE PORTION
OF THE SPENDING PLAN THAT'S
CHANGED ITS ON THE BACKSIDE OF
YOUR SHEET AND FIGURE FOR.
SO CONSISTENT WITH PAST
PROPOSALS THE MAY REVISION
CONTINUES TO FOCUS THE MAJORITY
OF THE SPENDING ON ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY PAYMENTS AND FOR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE THESE TYPES OF
PAYMENTS BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE
THE GREATEST FLEXIBILITY FOR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES.
ON THE ONE TIME CHARGE OF THE
VERY TOP
THAT.
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL PAYMENT
THAT'S GOING TOWARDS THIS
DISCRETIONARY PAYMENTS OF TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
MILLION DOLLARS.
BRINGING THE TOTAL PAYMENT TO
TWO BILLION.
OVER THE PAST FOUR FIVE YEARS IF
YOU INCLUDE THIS PAYMENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE RECEIVED SEVEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
DISCRETIONARY PAYMENTS.
ANOTHER.
NOTABLE CHANGE TO A A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION GRANT PROGRAM
ORIGINALLY AT THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL HAD FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND TEN THE FUNDING THAT
WAS PROVIDED AND THAT FUNDING IS
NO LONGER AVAILABLE SO THIS IS A
BACK PHILIP. GENERAL FUND.
WITH REGARDS TO NEW PROPOSALS
THERE'S A TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO CONVERT THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY
ASSESSMENT. EXAM TO A COMPUTER
BASED MODEL THIS AND ALSO
INCLUDES FUNDING TO DEVELOP AN
ALTERNATIVE TEST FOR STUDENTS
WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
THERE'S A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE SB SEVEN FORTY CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS IS TO FULFILL THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SHORTFALL ARM IN ORDER
TO ALIGN FUNDING WITH
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM IF
YOU RECALL THERE IS AN ONGOING A
PROPOSAL TO TAKE THE PROGRAM.
ALIGNMENT TO NEED IN THE OUT
YEARS.
I LOT THREE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS NEW.
IT'S A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
THIS INITIATIVE WILL UTILIZE THE
STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO
ASSIST COMMUNITIES IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENGAGE WITH EACH
OTHER MORE EFFECTIVELY. IT WILL
BE LED BY THE CALIFORNIA CLAPPER
TO FOR EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE A
ALONG WITH A A LEAD COUNTY
THAT'S BEEN CHOSEN.
AB THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ORANGE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND BUTTE COUNTY
OFFICE.
PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF HIGHER LEARNING HOW
TO EXPAND AND STUDY THE EXISTING
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM SUPPORT
FRAMEWORK. BUT TO FOCUS THIS ON
OF SCHOOL CLIMATE POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE.
FOR THE ONGOING EXPENDITURES
ARE SPENDING PROPOSALS AGAIN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
THE MAJORITY IS GOING TO THAT.
AND THERE'S A TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN THE
ALPHA FIVE THIS COVERS THE
INCREASE OF THE COLA COLA
PERCENTAGE WENT FROM TWO POINT
FIVE ONE PERCENT TO TWO POINT
SEVEN ONE PERCENT OVER THIS.
PERIOD I'M IN ADDITION THERE'S
AN A HUNDRED SIXTEEN.
IT'S MILLION DOLLAR BASED
INCREASE
A AND THAT WILL COVER THE
INCREASE IN SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANT AS WELL
THAT'S AN EFFECTIVE COLA OF
THREE PERCENT WHEN YOU OUT THE
WHO WOULDN'T SIX.
IN.
SO TOTAL FUNDING I'M IN THIS
PROPOSAL HEALTHY FF IS RECEIVING
AN INCREASE OF THREE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS.
ALL STATUTORY COLAS ARE
RECEIVING THE INCREASE TO THE
TWO POINT SEVEN ONE PERCENT IN
THIS PROPOSAL.
OTHERS ALSO A TWO MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE ON GOING FOR THE K.
TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROPOSAL. THIS IS TO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
OF THE REGIONAL CONSORTIA.
AND FINALLY ABOUT THIS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN
INCREASE PERFECT AMOUNT OF NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS. A THIS IS TO EXPAND IT
AFFECT THAT SUPPORT BOTH IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION BUT
ALSO TO OFFER MORE PROACTIVE AND
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WITH QUALIFIED
INTERIM BUDGET STATUSES IN OTHER
WORDS WILL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
BEGINNING TO SHOW SIGNS OF
PHYSICAL DISTRESS.
SAID THAT.
PRETTY MUCH COVERS THE MAJOR
PROPOSAL CHANGES ARE MADE VISION
FOR K. TWELVE I UNDERSTAND
YOU'LL BE CUTTING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROPOSALS ANOTHER
HEARINGS.
THANK YOU ELIA. A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KENNETH
UPON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'LL BE COVERING.
OR ANALYSIS OF THE GUARANTEE
AND THE CERTIFICATION PROPOSAL
BUT MY COLLEAGUE COVER SOME OF
THE SPECIFIC SPENDING PROPOSALS.
AND I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A
REPORT TO OUR OFFICE RELEASED
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
SO IF YOU HEARD THE
ADMINISTRATION SAY AND AS YOU
CAN SEE IN FIGURE ONE ON PAGE
THREE OF OUR REPORT. AT THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE OVER THE THREE
YEAR BUDGET PERIOD IS UP SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
OVER THE JNUARY BUDGET
ESTIMATES.
AND I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
GIVE YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE
SPECIFIC TESTS AND FACTORS BUT
STEPPING BACK A LITTLE BIT THE
WAY TO THINK ABOUT THAT
INCREASED REALLY IS THAT IT'S
THE RESULT OF TWO CHANGES.
BUT HALF OF THE INCREASE IS DUE
TO HIGHER REVENUE ESTIMATES
COMPARED JANUARY. AND THE OTHER
HALF IS DUE TO THAT A PROPOSAL
TO RE BENCH OR ADJUST THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE UPWARD.
AFTER THE SHIFT OF PRESCHOOL
COSTS THAT THE STATE.
INITIATED SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AS FAR AS THE GROWTH IN THE
GUARANTEED.
DESPAIR VISION REALLY IS ABOUT
AS GOOD AS IT GETS.
I REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE A FEW
BILLION HIGHER THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE PERIOD.
A MAINLY DUE TO OUR ESTIMATES OF
HIGHER PERSONAL INCOME TAX
REVENUE. BUT EVEN IF THOSE
ESTIMATES MIGHT WHICH
MATERIALIZE THE WAY WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR OUTLOOK THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE WOULDN'T BE
ANY HIGHER THAN WHAT. I EAT YOU
SEE TODAY.
IN FACT WE THINK THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN GUARANTEE I'M
NOT AS LIKELY TO BE SOMEWHAT
LOWER THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES
ESTIMATES.
AND THAT'S LARGELY DUE TO WHAT
DIFFERENCES I ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
STUDENT ATTENDANCE.
ADMINISTRATION SIMILAR TO
JANUARY. ASSUMES THAT IS ENOUGH
OF AN INCREASE IN ATTENDANCE TO
TRIGGER A SPECIAL. PROVISION IN
THE CONSTITUTION THAT AYE
PREVENTS THE GUARANTEE FROM
DROPPING.
A PRELIMINARY DATA FROM
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SUGGEST
THAT'S. NOT LIKELY TO BE THE
CASE
SO THE I GUARANTEE COULD END UP
A FEW HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BELOW. ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE MAYOR
VISION RIGHT NOW.
I TUNING TO PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE.
THAT WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES ARE A
LITTLE LOW THERE A GROWTH IN
HOUSING PRICES HAS BEEN VERY
STRONG OF LATE THE NUMBER OF NEW
BUILDING PERMITS ISSUED HAS BEEN
ON THE RISE.
SO WE THINK PROPERTY TAXES OVER
THE THREE YEARS I LIKELY TO BE
UP AROUND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES.
THAT'S REALLY SIGNIFICANT NOT SO
MUCH FOR ITS EFFECT ON SCHOOL
FUNDING PUT FOR THE WAY THAT
THAT FREES UP. HALF FUNDING FOR
OTHER PRIORITIES IN YOUR BUDGET.
TRYING TO CERTIFICATION I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION WALKED YOU
THROUGH KIND OF THE MECHANICS OF
HOW THAT WOULD WORK. ON OUR JUST
GIVE YOU A QUICK RECAP OF ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT PROPOSAL WHICH
IS THIS NEW PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT COST ALLOCATION SCHEDULE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A FAIRLY COMPLEX
PROPOSAL BUT IT'S REALLY
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
HUMILITY FAMILIARITY WEST ON
THIS COMMITTEE. WHICH IS THOSE
UNEXPECTED CHANGES IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE .
I'M TIMES THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
INCREASES AFTER WE ADOPT THE
BUDGET SOMETIMES IT FALLS AND
THE RESULT IS THAT A HIGH SCHOOL
FUNDING ARE RELATIVE TO THAT NEW
GUARANTEE IS OFTEN. A HIGHER
LOWER THAN WHAT YOU INTEND.
IN CASES WHERE THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS DROPPED.
BY THE STATE IN THE PAST HAS
OFTEN RESPONDED BY SCORING SOME
OF THAT MONEY ABOVE THE
GUARANTEE QUITE A DIFFERENT
FISCAL YEAR WHERE IT HASN'T
FULLY FUNDED THE GUARANTEE.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ESSENTIALLY IS TO AUTOMATE THAT
PROCESS AND SO AS PART OF A
REGULAR. ROUTINE BUDGET CLOSE UP
PROCESS
STATE WITHOUT FUNDING. AS CLOSE
TO THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AS
POSSIBLE.
AND THAT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
PREVENT YOU FROM FUNDING MORE
THAN THE GUARANTEE IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU INTEND. ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL A.
MAKE IT MORE LIKELY THAT THAT
WOULDN'T HAPPEN INADVERTENTLY.
OVERALL WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AT CERTIFICATION
PROPOSAL OFFER SOME CLEAR
ADVANTAGES OVER THE CURRENT
PRICE.
IT'S MY TRANSPARENT WITH THE
PUBLICATION THE FACTORS.
IT PROMOTES FASTER RESOLUTION OF
DISPUTES.
PLUS FINANCIALLY RISKY FOR THE
STATE.
IN SOME CASES THE STATE HAS HAD
TO RECOGNIZE SIGNIFICANT.
I INCREASES IN THE GUARANTEE
OFTEN MANY MANY YEARS AFTER THE
YEAR IS OVER AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T.
HAPPENED A FEW CERTIFIED IN
LOCKDOWN THE GUARANTEE IN A MORE
TIMELY WAY.
AND FINALLY WE THINK IT'S
THERE'S A CLEAR OUTLINE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IT LETS YOU HOLD
AYE ONE INDIVIDUAL THE DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
TIMELY CERTIFICATION OF THE
GUARANTEE
EACH YEAR.
AS WE RECOMMEND A APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I JUST WITH
ONE MODIFICATION TO REMOVE THE
CAP THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
TALKED ABOUT WE JUST THINK THAT
THAT ADDS SOME UNNECESSARY
COMPLEXITY. AND AND DOESN'T HELP
ADVANCE AUTO BUT THIS PROPOSAL
IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
I SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN THINGS
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO COVER
THE K. TWELVE. AND REALLY
EDUCATION PROPOSALS.
SEN JENNIFER CAN. I MAKE YOU
TURN THE PAGE A AND NINE OF THE
REPORT YOU CAN SEE THE BREAKDOWN
OF NINETY EIGHT FUNDING JUST FOR
KEY TWELVE EDUCATION.
AND ON FIGURE THREE YOU CAN SEE
ALL OF THAT ITEMIZE CHANGES AND
MAY BOTH ONGOING AND ONE TIME.
I FINANCE LAID THOSE OUT SO I
WAS GONNA SPEND MOST OF MY TIME
HERE ON FIGURE FOR WHICH IS
HITTING THE MAIN OF PAGE ELEVEN.
THE MAIN PROPOSALS AND MAY AND
OUR INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THEM.
AND SO HITTING SOME HIGHLIGHTS
ON THE DISCRETIONARY GRANTS THE
FUNDING HAS UP WE CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED THAT IF THE STATE USES
THE APPROACH IT'S BEEN USING OF
JUST GIVING IT OUT ON EIGHTY A
WITHOUT ANY REAL.
CONNECTION SOME MANDATES THE
STATE WILL NOT REDUCE THE
MANDATE BACKLOG IT'LL JUST ON
THE BOOKS FOR YEARS AND YEARS TO
COME.
ON THE ONGOING FUND IN THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION OF THAT A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX MILLION IS ON TOP OF
THE TARGETS.
SO YOU'VE BEEN TALKING
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR OF ONCE YOU
REACH THE TARGETS HOW MIGHT YOU
WANT TO SPEND ANY MONEY ABOVE
AND SO YOU JUST INDICATE THAT
YOU HAVE CHOICES ABOUT THAT.
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX MILLION
WHETHER YOU USE THAT AS THEY AS
THEY PROPOSE FOR INCREASES IN
ALL OF THE RATES COMPARABLY OR
INVESTED IN THE BASE OR THE
SUPPLEMENT YOU HAVE CHOICES IN
THAT REGARD.
WITH AUTOMATING THE COLA FOR
ELSE YOU HAVE TO. PUT UP GRADINA
AND TAKING IT OUT OF THE BUDGET
CONVERSATION WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECT THAT PIECE OF THAT THIS
IS THE ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
BUDGET DECISIONS YOU MAKE EVERY
YEAR. IS HOW MUCH DO YOU WANNA
AUGMENT LCF OFF BY.
SO WHEN WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE
TO CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE LAST
YEAR'S BASS AS ADJUSTED FOR
INCUMBENTS THOSE ARE MORE
AUTOMATIC BUT IF YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE AN AUGMENTATION WE
SUGGEST YOU RETAIN NOT AUTHORITY
INSIDE THE CONTEXT OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS.
THEY HAVE TO PROPOSALS AND MAY
RELATED SU WHAT'S CALLED THE L.
PACK OR THE NEW STYLE TO THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROFESSOR
PROFICIENCY EXAM.
ONE IS TWENTY TWO MILLION TO
MAKE WHAT IS NOW PAN AND AND
PENCIL I'M SORRY PENCIL AND
PAPER INTO COMPUTER.
COMPUTER BASED.
.
THE COST ESTIMATE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISE IS ABOUT TWICE
WHAT IT COST JUST TO DEVELOP THE
TYPE.
AND ALL THAT'S HAPPENING IS
MOVING UP FROM THE PAPER VERSION
TO THE COMPUTER VERSION IT'S NOT
A COMPUTER ADAPTIVE TEST IT
REALLY IS JUST ALLOWING THE TASK
TO BE MADE. ON COMPUTER SO WE
THINK THIS IS MUCH TOO EXPENSIVE
SO JUST YEAR ADOPTED FOR THE
TIME BEING ASK FOR A BIAS
PROPOSAL NEXT YEAR.
THERE'S SIX MILLION BEING
REQUESTED FOR.
ALTERNATIVE EL CAP THAT WOULD
SERVE STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
THE STATE TO DATE HAS NEVER HAD
SUCH A TASK.
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
TAKE THE TUSTIN ALTERNATIVE TEST
EACH YEAR AND RIGHT NOW I A P.
TEAMS ARE DECIDING WHAT
ALTERNATIVE TO USE.
THERE COULD BE A CASE TO BE MADE
THOUGHT THERE SHOULD BE A
UNIFORM ALTERNATIVE BUT IT ISN'T
ENTIRELY CLEAR AT THIS POINT
WHETHER THAT'S ESSENTIAL.
SO HERE WE ARE JUST ADJUSTING
GIVE ME. DON'T JUDGMENT CLARA
YOU TALK ABOUT THE EL PACK YES
THAT THE THE NEW SELF IF YOU ASK
I THINK.
SO ON THIS ONE IS TO CREATE AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT WOULD BE FOR
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS BUT
AGAIN THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE IT
TO DATE THERE'S A. FEW STUDENTS
THAT TAKE THAT OUT SO THIS IS
JUST ADJUSTING ON THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS OF THE DEPARTMENT
CAN CLARIFY THAT IT IS REQUIRED
THAT THE STATE PROCEED IN THIS
FASHION. YOU COULD WITHHOLD AND
AGAIN REVISIT NEXT YEAR YOU
COULD GET BETTER ABSTINENCE
ABOUT THE PROJECT ITSELF HOW
MUCH IT WILL COST.
THE PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW IN BED AT
THE TO THE ONE FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT AND THE
COMPUTER ASSESSMENT SO IT'S HARD
FOR US RIGHT NOW TO DISENTANGLE
IF YOU ONLY DID WANTED TO DO ONE
OR THE OTHER.
ON THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
GRANT PROGRAM YOU MIGHT RECALL
THAT LAST YEAR YOU INCREASE THE
GRANTS AMOUNT FROM SEVEN FIFTY
TO ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER STUDENT. AND AT THE TIME IT
WAS AN UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
COULD DO THAT WITHIN THE
AND TWELVE MILLION.
THE ESTIMATES AT THE TIME WERE
NOT VERY GOOD SO THE PROGRAM IS
COMING IN MUCH MORE EXPENSE OF
TODAY. AND THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSAL HAS.
PROPOSALS TO COVER THE SHORTFALL
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND THEN
AUGMENT AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
BUT WE WAS JUST UP THE US MINT
STILL HURT VERY GOOD SO IN
RUNNING INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENTS
WE THINK IF YOU WANNA GET AT
THIS HIGHER LEVEL THE ELEVEN
HUNDRED IT WOULD TAKE MORE MONEY
IN BOTH YEARS.
SO WE HAVE THE ESTIMATES HERO
CHICK TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR SO IS A LOT OF MONEY
ON THE TABLE THE PROGRAM AGAIN
AS A HUNDRED AND TWELVE BILLION
LAST YEAR SO PROVIDING A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION A
SUBSTANTIAL.
SO WE ALSO GIVE YOU JUST AN
OPTION IF YOU WANTED TO GO BACK
TO THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PER PUPIL MAX MIGHT NOT COST
SUBSTANTIALLY LAST IT'S STILL
COST MORE THAN LAST YEAR EIGHT
MILLION.
ON THE SCHOOL CLIMATE INITIATIVE
THIS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
IT'S BUILT OFF OF THIS MULTI
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WHICH
IS JUST A TERMINOLOGY THAT'S
BEING USED FOR CHINA HAVE
STRATEGIES FOR DEALING LARGELY
WITH BEHAVIORAL ISSUES IN
DEALING WITH A IN THE GENERAL
EDUCATION CITING.
THE STATE PROVIDED THIRTY
MILLION TO THESE TWO COUNTY
OFFICES TO DO WORK LIKE THIS
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO. AND SO
IT'S UNCLEAR Y. THERE'S STILL AN
ISSUE OUT THERE WHAT EXACTLY IS
THE ISSUE OUT THERE.
AND MORE OVER SO THE
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T REALLY
TELL YOU WHAT IS ADDED WHAT'S
SPECIAL ABOUT THIS PART OF MONEY
VERSUS THE THIRTY MILLION YARDI
PROVIDED. BUT IT WON'T GIVE YOU
AN EXPENDITURE PLAN UNTIL
DECEMBER SO IT'S ASKING YOU TO
PROVE FIFTY MILLION YOU'RE NOT
REALLY GONNA KNOW HOW THE MONIES
WILL BE SPENT. AND YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT UNIQUE PROBLEM YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE YOU WON'T BE
ABLE TO TRACK WHETHER YOU'VE
SOLVED AT A YEAR FROM NOW.
ON THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROPOSAL IT'S A PRETTY MODEST
CHANGE TO JUST ADD THE TWO
MILLION FOR ADMINISTRATION WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE ALL THE SAME
ISSUES WITH HOT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THE NEXT THREE PROPOSALS LISTED
ON FIGURE FOR OUR ALL WITH THIS
NEW SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR LOW
PERFORMING DISTRICTS.
THE MAY REVISION TRIES TO LAND A
LOT MORE CLARITY TO WHAT COUNTY
OFFICES ARE DOING AND SO IF YOU
WANT COUNTIES TO BE AGAIN WE
WERE SUGGESTING YOU DON'T TAKE
THIS APPROACH BUT IF YOU DO IF
YOU WANT COUNTIES TO BE THE CORE
SUPPORT PROVIDER. WE THINK SOME
OTHER CLARIFICATIONS ARE USEFUL
AND YOU COULD GO EVEN FURTHER
YOU COULD JUST CLARIFY THAT
COUNTIES ARE THE ONES TO DO THAT
ON A VACATION OF ROOT CAUSES.
THE PERFORMANCE DATA REVIEW AND
TO HELP IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES FOR REFORM. AND THEN
YOU CAN HAVE THE COLLABORATIVE
GO AHEAD AND SUPPORT COUNTIES
AND HAVING THE CAPACITY TO DO
THAT. THEY'RE STILL THIS WHOLE
REGIONAL LEVEL THAT WE THINK IS
EXTRANEOUS AND COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
BECAUSE IF YOU DO BILL THAT
REGIONAL LAYER YOU WON'T KNOW
WHO TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE IS THAT
THE COUNTY IS THE RETURNS AT THE
COLLABORATIVE THE ROLES BECOME
VERY.
INTERTWINED IN A WAY THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY BECOMES ALMOST.
I WAS VERY VERY DIFFICULT.
THE LAST ONE IS FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENTS THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COLLABORATIVE TO
DO PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
NETWORKS ON COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
THE COLLABORATIVE RIGHT NOW DOES
FIFTY SIX OF THE USE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS.
SO WE THINK IF YOU REALLY WANT
ONE ARE MORE OF THEM TO DO
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT YOU COULD
JUST WRITE BUDGET PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WITHIN THE
COLLABORATIVE AND DIRECT THEM TO
DO THAT WE DON'T THINK THEY NEED
MORE MONEY FOR IT.
YOUR AGENDA ALSO COVERS EARLY
EDUCATION AND THERE'S ONLY
THERE'S FEWER ISSUES AND EARLY
HEAD BUT IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN. YOU CAN
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN CHILDCARE
AND PRESCHOOL.
WHEN YOU COMPARE THEM A REVISION
TO THE JANUARY BUDGETON THE
BOTTOM LINE NOT MUCH CHANGE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK OVER AT FIGURE
SIX ON PAGE FIFTEEN YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON THAT'S
NETTING OUT TO A BOTTOM LINE
THAT WERE ISN'T CHANGING.
PARTICULARLY MUCH.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR FIGURE
SEVEN PAGE SIXTEEN I'M JUST
GONNA HIGHLIGHT THE BIG MOVING
PIECES SO THE BIGGEST ISSUE
BEFORE YOU. IS THAT POWER X.
CHILDCARE ESTIMATES ARE COMING A
MUCH HIGHER THAN EXPECTED.
YOU MAY RECALL LAST YEAR THE
STATE DID SOME PRETTY IMPORTANT
POLICY CHANGES THEY SAID RATHER
THAN A FAMILY HAVING TO MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
THEY ONLY HAD TO MAINTAIN IT AT
A POINT IN TIME. DURING THE YEAR
AND THEN THEY INCREASE
PREVIOUSLY THE STATE JUST HAD AN
ENTRY AND EXIT THRESHOLD THAT
WAS A TENTACLE SEVENTY PERCENT
OF THE STATE MEDIAN INCOME. THE
STATE CREATED AN ACCESS
THRESHOLD WHICH WAS EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE STATE MEDIAN
INCOME. AND THEY ALSO CHANGE THE
INDEX THEY WERE USING FROM TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN INDEX TO A TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND DUCKS THIS MEANT
THAT THE EXIT THRESHOLD FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE MOVE FROM
SOMETHING LIKE FORTY THOUSAND TO
SIXTY THOUSAND.
SO THE ESTIMATES AT THE TIME OF
WHAT IT WOULD COST TO DO THESE
THINGS AGAIN WE'RE NOT
PARTICULARLY GOOD SO THE COSTS
ARE COMING AND SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER. YOU JUST AROUND A
SECTION LETTER TO FUND A
DEFICIENCY AND COWARDS CHILDCARE
HERE A FEW WEEKS AGO. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION INCLUDES
A HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO COVER THESE COSTS.
AB BUT WE THINK IT'S FALLING
SHORT OF WHAT YOU REALLY NEED TO
COVER THE COST WE THINK THE COST
IS PROBABLY AT LEAST FIFTY NOTES
FIFTY MILLION MORE. AND THIS IS
USING OUR CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES
WE THINK OCCUR COME ON IN AS
HIGH AS SEVENTY FIVE MILLION OR
MORE.
SO IF YOU DON'T PROVIDE THE
AUGMENTATION OF AN EXTRA FIFTY
YOU CAN FIND YOURSELF IN A
POSITION SIX MONTHS FROM NOW
WHERE THE PROGRAM HAS A
SHORTFALL YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
IF THERE ARE RESOURCES THAT THAT
TIME TO COVER IT WE DON'T
RECOMMEND YOU COVER IT NOW.
FOR EARLY AND AND THERE'S NO
MAJOR CHANGES TO THE INITIATIVE
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE ALL OUR SING
CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE GOT A LOT
OF MONEY YOU COULD BE USING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW TO HELP CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WORK WITH STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
SO YOU HAVE ABOUT NINETY THREE
MILLION YOU ARE THE PROVIDING
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT MONIES ABOUT
HALF OF WHICH GOES TO TRAINING.
IN THE MAY REVISION THERE'S
ANOTHER SEVENTEEN MILLION AND
FEDERAL CARRYOVER THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY USED FOR TRAINING.
AND THEN THE STATE WAS NOTIFIED
JUST WITHIN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
THAT IT'S GOING TO GET TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
BOTH IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
AGAIN IN NINETEEN TWENTY. THAT
IT CAN USE FOR A VARIETY OF
PURPOSES TRAINING BEING ONE SO
WE THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF MONEY
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IT'S JUST ATTACHING THE
MONEY AND THE PRIORITY THOUGHTS
ARE IN YOUR BUDGET.
AND THEN LASTLY.
SEDIA IS REQUESTING SOME MONEY
TO ADMINISTER THESE COUNTY PILOT
PROGRAMS.
I MEAN WE WERE JUST.
RECOMMEND YOU REVISIT IT NEXT
YEAR.
CD GIVE US A PROPOSAL IN THE
FALL BUT IT WAS BEFORE YOU TOOK
ACTION AND MAY I'M SORRY AND
MARCH TO STREAMLINE ASPECTS OF
THE PROGRAM SO IT SHOULD BE
EASIER FOR THEM TO ADMINISTRATE.
AND ADMINISTER THE PILOTS RIGHT
NOW THEY HAVE VERY SIMILAR RULES
NOW.
AND THAT INFORMATION WE'VE
GOTTEN TO DATE DOESN'T SPECIFY
ALL THE THINGS THEY NO LONGER
NEED TO DO BECAUSE THE COUNTIES
ARE IN THE PILOT AND NOT IN THE
REGULAR PROGRAM SO THERE'S ABOUT
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE SLOTS
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE REGULAR
PROGRAM IN CD WOULD HAVE BEEN.
DOING WORK ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
AND HAVEN'T SORT OF BACKED OUT
THE SAVINGS TO GET FROM NO
LONGER HAVING TO DO THAT WORK SO
IF THE DEPARTMENT WOULD COME
BACK NEXT YEAR SORT OF NET OUT
THEN YOU COULD REVISIT THAT THE
PROPOSAL AT THAT TIME.
SO THAT'S A REVIEW OF THE KEY
TWELVE AND EARLY ADD ME REVISE
PURPLES.
THANK YOU.
SURE NICK SCHWEITZER DEPARTMENT
HEAD.
SO YOU KNOW GENERALLY WERE WERE
WERE POSITIVE ON THIS MAY
REVISION.
US START WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT
WE CERTAINLY VERY STRONGLY AS
SUPPORT THE STREAMLINED
CERTIFICATION LANGUAGE.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
UNDER APPROPRIATIONS BE
IDENTIFY QUICKLY IN THAT MONEY
BE.
DISTRIBUTED TO SCHOOLS
EXPEDITIOUSLY. ARE WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE RE BRANCHING OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT FOR THE FULL DAY
PRESCHOOL.
AUGMENTATION THAT WAS DONE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
FINALLY WITH REGARD TO THE COST
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE WE BELIEVE
THIS IS CERTAINLY A MUCH BETTER
ALTERNATIVE TO OTHER MECHANISMS
THAT MAY. BE USED TO LIMIT OVER
APPROPRIATIONS SUCH AS CLAW
BACKS AND OR DELAYING.
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS WHICH WE'VE
SEEN PROPOSED IN THE PAST.
.
AND THEN WE WE VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE THE.
.
THE.
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF EL
CFF AND THE.
GRANTING OF THE AUTOMATIC COOL
WAS.
WE THINK THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE CONTINUED
STABILITY OF OF SCHOOL FUNDING.
WORK WITH REGARD TO THE EL PACK.
HERE WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE THERE
IS A VALUE TO DELIVERING THAT
ASSESSMENT VIA COMPUTERS AND WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT FOR THE
OPAC IS IS REQUIRED.
WE'RE GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTING
THE. THE EL PACK NEXT YEARS SO
IT'S AN IMPORTANT TO.
BEGIN NEW MOVING TO GET THOSE
THOSE PIECES IN PLACE.
.
EARLY EDUCATION.
Y. CALL OUT THE EARLY THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSAL FROM THE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IS AND. FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION GENERAL WE'RE MOVING
TOWARDS INCLUSION EARLY
EDUCATION SHOULDN'T BE ANY
DIFFERENT.
BEYOND THIS THIS IS GOING TO
HELP SUPPORT.
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION FOR
EARLIER EDUCATION.
I'M.
THE OTHER THING ON EARLY HEAD
IS WERE REGARD WITH REGARD TO
THE PILOTS.
THOSE PILOTS WHO ARE NINE OF
THEM WERE PROVED THAT LAST YEAR
AND.
WE THINK THE THE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO US TOO AT BEGIN.
IMPLEMENTING THOSE THOSE PILOTS
IS IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR
THEM TO.
.
MOVE FORWARD SUCCESSFULLY.
THEN FINALLY.
WANNA CALL OUT ONE AREA OF
CONCERN CONTINUED CONCERN WITH
THE MAYOR VISION AND THAT IS OF
COURSE WITH THE.
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S.
EFFORTS TO REACH OUT AND AND.
MODIFY THE PROPOSAL BASED ON
INPUT FROM THE FIELD.
BUT ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW WE WE
CAN.
CAN YOU TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THOUGH THE ROLE OF K. TWELVE AND
AND THE INFLUENCE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND CONSORTIUM LEVEL. AND
SERVE YOU KNOW HOW HOW THIS
PROGRAM CAN BE BEST ALIGNED WITH
THE EXISTING.
K. TWELVE CD PROGRAM ARE QUE
TWELVE CT  PROGRAMS
AS.
.
BASED ON THE.
THE WAY THE ADMINISTRATION
CURRENTLY PROPOSING TO.
.
HAVE THE PROGRAM ADMINISTERED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS ALL OF A FEW BUT
FIRST MR O'DONNELL. BUT THANK
YOU ARE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
ON MY FIRST QUESTION MAY BECOME
AN A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CERTIFICATION OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT GIVES ME A LOT OF CONCERN.
MY BASIC CONCERN IS THAT IF
FURTHER EMPOWERS THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OVER THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS A BIT
AYE CHANGES THAT SEE CHANGES THE
PROCESS FOR CERTIFYING THE FINAL
CALCULATION.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR GUARANTEED
THE GUARANTEE FOR PRIOR YEARS.
CURRENTLY IT'S DONE BY A TEAM
RIGHT THE S. P. AYE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ENGAGE IN THAT NOW IS
THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS THE YES CORRECT CLICK
THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE SINCE
THREE THOUSAND EIGHT NINE.
GREAT.
.
BUT THIS PROPOSAL LAWS TO PART
OF FIGHTS ALONE. TO DETERMINE
WHAT THAT LEVEL
SHOULD BE.
IN THE LAST PART OF FINANCE TO
COUNT ANY FUNNY ABOVE THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE TO MEET FUTURE
PROP NINETY EIGHT OBLIGATIONS.
SO YOU MIGHT MIGHT THEM INTO MY
OVERALL PERCEPTION AGAIN AS IT
EMPOWERS THE.
REJECT EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
MORE THAN.
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
AND IT ALONE OF THE NET EFFECT
WILL BE THAT IT IT MAKES THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE A
MAXIMUM AS WELL AS A MINIMUM.
AND WHAT IF WE INTEND TO GO
ABOVE.
THE THE MINIMUM LEVEL.
IN THEY'RE THERE'S BEEN A
PREVIOUS COURT CASE PREVIOUS
COURT CASE NEW CTE VERSE CALL
COOL WHERE I'D MIKE TO DO
KNOWLEDGE IS BOTH SPEECHES JUST
IF YOU COULD JUST WE CAN FINISH
HIS THOUGHTS.
THIS THIS CONFLICT WITH THAT IS
THAT VIOLATE.
THAT AGREEMENT AGAIN WHAT'S
WRONG WITH.
FUNDING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT.
OVER THE MINIMUM I OR FORTY SIX
THE NATION GIVE OR TAKE.
ON A PER PUPIL FUNDING SO SO
THIS THIS THIS PROPOSAL GIVES ME
A LOT OF CONCERN AND I'M
WONDERING WHY ARE WE DOING THIS.
SO VIRTUAL Y. READING THIS
SIGNAL WHAT YOU BELIEVE THEN
THAT AFFECTS BECAUSE AGAIN I I
BELIEVE THAT THE THE SEACM THAT
MOST SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS THAT
AGAIN IT EMPOWERS THE.
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
IF I MAY ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO
THIS PROCESS REALLY IS NOT ON
SIMILAR A IT IT'S VERY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING SO IT IN PAST
CERTIFICATIONS OF THE THE S. P.
AYE THE CHANCELLOR'S. OFFICE
THEY PROVIDE FINANCE WITH ALL OF
THE ALLOCATIONS APPROPRIATIONS
PROPERTY TAXES FTS IS IN A.
THEIR EIGHTY A AND SO THEY
WOULD COMPILE THAT INFORMATION
BUT FINANCE HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
ONE THE KINDS THAT'S THE
GUARANTEE. WE AND THE FACTORS
ARE ALL SAID IN LAW AS THEY
STAND SO.
IT REALLY JUST MAKES IT A MORE
FORMAL PROCESS AND DOESN'T THEN
REQUIRE.
EVERYONE TO SIGN OFF ON IT IT
JUST IT'S POSTED HOWEVER THERE
IS THAT PERIOD WHERE EVERYONE
CAN.
SPEWED IT AND THAT.
AGAIN NOW IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT'S
GOING ON NOW AT LEAST THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WOULD BE
GOING FORWARD SO THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANY MORE POWER
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH WHICH
THAT'S PRETTY CONSISTENT IT HAS
ACTUALLY. BUT AGAIN WHY CHANGE
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE NO I
DON'T I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
ACCOMPLISHES BY CHANGING THE
EXISTING PROCESS OTHER THAN.
SOLIDIFIES POWER.
ALSO THE EXISTING PROCESS THERE
IS IS NOT WORKING THIS IS WHY
IT'S NOT BEEN CERTIFIED SINCE A
NOT ABSENCE. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
NINE BECAUSE THEY HAVE AGREED OF
TO HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHY IT IS
WORKING THERE'S SEVERAL PROBABLE
SO FIRST OF ALL THE PROCESS THE
NINE MONTH THE TIME FRAME IS TOO
SHORT FINAL FACTORS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE SO WE'D BE ACTUALLY
CERTIFYING PRIOR TO EVEN HAVING
THE LAST.
LOOK AT REVENUE THAT'S.
AND THERE'S SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
YU CAN SEE IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
RIGHT NOW WE JUST AT MAY
REVISION CHANGED REVENUES AND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS SO. SO
THERE'S THAT AND THEN ALSO
THERE'S JUST BEEN ONGOING
INTERPRETATION DIFFERENCES THIS
WOULD JUST SORT OF FORCED THE
CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN ANNUALLY
AND SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS NOW AS
OPPOSED TO. KICKING THAT. THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND CANS DOWN THE
ROAD TO DO YOU SEE THE NET
RESULT.
IN IS THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT THE
GUARANTEE WOULD BE A MAXIMUM WAS
WELL AS A MINIMUM THAT PUT THAT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE CAN BE SET AT
ANY LEVEL THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINES IT TO BE SO YOU CAN
OVER TO PROGRAM AND PROVIDE. YOU
CAN PROVIDE AS MUCH AS YOU WANT
TO THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED THIS
JUST GIVES THE STATE SOME
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THE WHEN WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY THAT
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT.
SO THE MINIMUM GUARANTEES OF
APPROPRIATED REVENUES.
DROP SUBSTANTIALLY MAY GIVE SOME
LIMITED FLEXIBILITY AGAIN THE
ONE PERCENT CAP WOULD ONLY ALLOW
THAT JUST WENT UP TO YOU KNOW IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
DO ANY OTHERS WAS STILL PLAYING
ON THE.
DELEO. NOT OR MAYBE JUST A YOU
KNOW THIRTY OF ONE PERSPECTIVE
ON THE POWER OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH THE WAY THAT THE PROCESS.
WORKS NOW EVEN THOUGH IN THEORY
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
CHANCELLOR SIGNED OFF ON US
IN REALITY ALL OF OUR PROP
NINETY EIGHT CALCULATIONS.
BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
GUARANTEE OF OUR REFLECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES
THE ONLY EXCEPTIONS OVER THE
YEARS HAVE BEEN. WHEN YOU USE
YOUR LEVERAGE TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO.
SORT OF REACH AN ALTERNATIVE
AGREEMENT TO USE A DIFFERENT
ESTIMATE OF THE WORD BEING
LEVERAGED.
SO.
I I THINK WHATEVER WHATEVER
CERTIFICATION YOU PROCESS YOU
ADOPT
AND WHETHER IT'S.
WHAT IT LOOKS MORE LIKE THE WAY
YOU KEEP THE OLD PROCESS OF THE
NEW PROCESS MEAN YOUR A SORT OF?
ROLL AND CERTIFICATION WILL BE.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AND.
UNDER THE YOU KNOW IN SOME SOME
OF THE FACTORS LIKE REVENUE
AREN'T REALLY FINAL AT.
IN MAY REVISION BUT NEVER THE
LESS THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO AGREE ON
THOSE FACTORS IN THE BUDGET. AND
THROUGH THAT.
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATING WITH THE
GOVERNOR YOU COULDN'T YOU COULD
ADOPT A DIFFERENT ESTIMATES THAT
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
TOP PROPOSES IS PART OF THAT
TENTATIVE CERTIFICATION.
THANK YOU I THINK AGAIN I THINK
THE KEY WORD USER WAS LEVERAGE
AND THAT THAT THAT THAT WORD.
GIVES ME CONCERNS THAT THAT
ACTUALLY MAY BE THE MOTIVE.
THERE YET SO I WOULD I WOULD PUT
OUT FROM FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT
IT'S ONLY THE.
THIS INITIAL SERVE OCCASIONS
GONNA HAPPEN AFTER THE BUDGET
BUT CHARLIE OWN FUTURES
CERTIFICATIONS AS AS THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED. ARE KIND
OF A LINE WITH THE MAY REVISION
WERE THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
ANNOUNCE THEIR THEIR FINDINGS
AND THE DATA BUT FINE BEHIND
THEM AT THE TIME OF MAY REVISION
AND THEN ALLOW FOLKS TO WEIGH
IN.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD WAY AND.
THROUGH THAT MAY REVISION
PROCESS AND DURING THE THE
BUDGET ADOPTION PROCESS I'M THE
THE ONLY THE ONLY ISSUE WOULD BE
A SO THAT. THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
DO THAT.
WILL BE SHORT BUT. IT'S ALL IN
YOUR MAY REVISIONS ALWAYS A
CRUNCH SO SO DOES THE
SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORT THIS
CHANGE YET.
HE DOES SUPPORT DISEASE.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN A COUPLE OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
.
THIS IS.
THIS IS GONNA GO TO THE THE.
CE CC IS THAT CORRECT.
I YOUNG THOUGHTS BERMAN OF
FINANCE SO THAT THEIR TWO POINT
THREE MILLION AND INITIATIVE IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE GOING TO
CEASE  AS WELL AS THE CO
LEAD REGION AND THIS WAS ONE OF
SANTA CO AT AT THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION CO LEAD. TO THE
BECAUSE LEADING THIS INITIATIVE.
SO DOES ADMINISTERING THE MONEY
GET ME TELL YOU MY CONCERN MY
CONCERN DE.
IT MAY BE.
IT MAY NOT EVEN BE ALLOWED KICK
IN THIS MONEY GET DOWN TO NON
PROFITS.
I GUESS SO MY MY CONCERNS AND
NONPROFITS ARE GONNA GET ON THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT TRAIN.
SEEK A BUNCH OF MONEY.
RIGHT AND NOT BE EFFECTIVE.
AND I'M PRETTY BLUNT MIGHT.
QUESTION THERE MAYBE YOU CAN SO
WE'RE NOT PRESCRIPTIVE IN OUR
LANGUAGE.
AROUND THIS INITIATIVE SO THAT
THIS.
THIS INITIATIVE IS BUT UP INTO
THREE KIND OF FEEDS US OF THE
FIRST PHASE. WILL BE CONVENING
OF ONE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
NETWORK COMPRISED OF SCHOOLS
THAT STAFF DISTRICT STAFF
PARENTS.
AND IT COULD BE EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS BUT THEM THE MAIN
POINT OF THIS INITIATIVE IS TO
IMPROVE. AND THE PARENT EASEMENT
ASPECT OF OF LC ABOUT OF OF.
OKAY.
SO.
I'M SORRY DID I ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ARMY EFFORT THANK YOU.
THEY CAN THEN THE QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO THEIR BUT DID THIS CT
.
AND MAYBE A STEP FOR THE PART OF
FINANCE ON THERE'S GONNA BE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE FORMED KIDDING
WE ATE WE OTHER PROPOSAL THE NEW
CD PROPOSAL WITH TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ON GOING. AND THEN THE
CONSORTIA NOW OR ADDING IN THE
K. TWELVE SELECTION COMMITTEE.
SO THERE'S THERE'S MORE
BUREAUCRACY WHAT WHAT IS THEIR
FUNCTION.
VERSES
VERSUS THE CONSORTIA DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
EVER ALEXANDER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE KEY TWELVE SELECTION
COMMITTEE WAS WAS PREVIOUSLY IN
THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
KNOWN AS THE K. TWELVE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO THAT'S NOT A NEW
COMPONENT TO THEM A REVISED
PROPOSAL. AND THAT IS A
COMMITTEE THAT'S GOING TO BE
FORMED BY THE CONSORTIA IN THEY
WILL BE CHARGED WITH MAKING THE
CURRENT DETERMINATIONS AS WELL
AS.
.
THEY IT BE IT AMOUNT PER GRANT
SO THE CONSUMER HOUSES CAN WORK
SO THAT WE FORM CONSORTIA AND
THEN THEY FORM A COMMITTEE WHO
SELECTS THE COMMITTEE. AND.
THAT OTHER GOING ON FLIGHTS
WITHIN THE COMMITTEE OTHER
POLITICAL BATTLES WHEN THE
COMMITTEE TO THE MONEY THAT'S MY
CONCERN AS WELL CONSORTIUM
PROPOSAL BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T IT
DEVOLVE INTO A BATTLE OVER
DOLLARS SO THE COMMITTEE IS
FORMED BY THE CONSORTIUM SO THE
CONSORTIUM'S THE WHEN SELECTING
WHO WILL SIT. ON THAT COMMITTEE
ON THE MAY REVISE LANGUAGE DOES
LAY OUT.
* THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP
SO.
IT'LL BE COMPRISED OF CURRENT
OR FORMER CLAY GOT WHILE AGAIN
BUT YOU HAVE TO WE WE DO HAVE
THOSE P. SAYS.
WITH THE CONTROL FOR BIAS THERE
IS A PROVISION IN THE MAY REVISE
THAT IF YOU ARE A DISTRICT OR
COUNTY OFFICE WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE WHO IS SITTING ON
THAT HE TWELFTH SELECTION
COMMITTEE. THAT YOU HAVE PROPER
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED NOT
CONFLICT WITH DECISIONS BEING
MADE.
JETS I STILL THINK THAT'S A.
MORE GOVERNMENT AND AGAIN MORE
GOVERNMENTS THAT THAT THAT'S
WHERE I DON'T KNOW WHY THE
INCENTIVE GRANT.
DIDN'T WORK TEAMWORK MY
PERSPECTIVE
SO.
I JUST WORRY THAT WE'RE CREATING
MORE HURDLES AND MORE
BUREAUCRACIES.
BUT THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
AND MY NEXT.
QUESTION MAYBE THROUGH THE
AUDIO ON THE OPAC TEST.
SO THAT THAT'S GOING TO WORK
TAKE WERE SEEKING TO TAKE THAT
ELECTRONIC.
IN SO TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
TIMELINE BECAUSE THERE'S AN
ISSUES IN THE PAST.
AND KEY TWELVE SCHOOL STRIDES
WITH.
IN IDENTIFYING STUDENTS AND.
IN ASSESSING THEM IN A CERTAIN
TIMEFRAME.
SO THAT WE GET THEM RECLASSIFIED
IF NEED BE CAN YOU CAN YOU SPEAK
TO HOW HOW THAT'S GOING TO
IMPACT. OUR COMPORT WITH EFFORTS
TO GET THE TEST IN AN EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
DO YOU KNOW TODAY.
I'M AND HASN'T BEEN ARTICULATED
TO US THAT AN OBJECTIVE OF
MOVING FROM PAPER TO COMPUTER.
IS TO.
NECESSARILY EXPEDITE
REDESIGNATIONS ALTHOUGH A
COMPUTER BASED SYSTEM THEY DO
TONS OF BE ABLE TO TRANSFER
INFORMATION MORE QUICKLY TO
TEACHERS SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
IF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD
AMENDED ADS ELT AND RE
CLASSIFICATION POLICIES. THAT
JUST BY HAVING BY VIRTUE OF
HAVING THEM FOR MISSION MORE
QUICKLY THEY COULD RE DOESN'T ME
SOONER BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S
A REQUIREMENT THAT THEY GO THAT
NEXT STEP AND JUST BECAUSE THE
TEACHER HAS THE BENEFIT OF THE
DATA. THAT IT'S TRANSFERRED TO
THE NEXT TEACHER AND NOT RE
CLASSIFICATION OCCURS OR
DESIGNATION ACROSS MORE QUICKLY.
BUT AGAIN THE PROPOSAL IS COMING
PRETTY QUICK BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT.
YOU'RE GONNA GET A LOT OF DETAIL
OKAY.
I HOPE SOMEONE HAS MORE NOT
COUNTING ON YOU TO HAVE THEM
TODAY UP.
BUT SO SO.
A TEST TO BE DELIVERED A
CLASSROOM SETTING.
STUDENTS PULLED OUT.
HOWEVER IT WORKS LOGISTICALLY
AND THEN THE RESULTS ARE SENT TO
A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR WHO THEN
ASSESSES.
STUDENT.
PERFORMANCE.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU ONE OF MY
CONCERNS WHEN I CONCERNS IS.
WE GIVE A STUDENT TESTS AND I
THINK THE TEACHER EVEN
PARTICIPATING GRADING SOME OF IT
THEN IT SENT OFF TO A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR MOURNER WEISS WE SEND
ANY OF IT OFF TO A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR.
IF IF ISSUE IF IT TEACHERS ARE
ENGAGING. IN THE ASSESSMENT OF
THE STUDENT WONDER HOW EFFECTIVE
IT IS
TO SEND IT OFF TO A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR MAY THAT'S A MUCH
MORE RHETORICAL QUESTION.
BUT.
GIVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THE.
WELL I SUSPECT THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT'S PAPER
COMPUTER I SUSPECT CD IS USING A
VENDOR TO DEVELOP A TEST SINCE
THE TEST WAS RATHER RECENTLY
DEVELOPED THE CONVERSION FROM
SOME OUTSIDE HELP PAT. AND I
SUSPECT THAT A PORTION OF NOT
ALL I A GOOD PORTION OF IT IS
GREAT IT EFFECTIVELY IN A DATA
IS TRANSFERRED IN TERMS OF
SCORES BETWEEN THE VENDOR IN THE
STATE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
ANY COMMENT ON A SPECIFIC
LOGISTICS THE TIMELINE TO GET
THIS TEST.
YOU KNOW.
PERFORMED AND THEN AND THEN THE
RESULTS BACK THAT THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
STUDENTS ARE GETTING
RECLASSIFIED TIME FOR THE NEXT
YEAR. AND THEN.
YEAH I'M CERTAINLY NOT THE
EXPERT ON ON THIS EXAM OR OR HOW
IT'S ADMINISTERED AND WOOD PRY
NEED TO GET BACK TO YOUR MORE
INFORMATION BUT COULD YOU IF YOU
DON'T HAVE DAY THAT'S FINE FOR
SURE AND IT JUST GENERALLY YOU
KNOW COMPUTER BASED TESTS. CAN
ALLOW FOR MORE MORE EFFICIENCIES
AND IN IN SCORING EXAMS THAN
EIGHT CANCER YOUR QUESTION THAT
AS TO WHY CONTRACTORS DO THE DO
SCORING'S IN IN GENERAL. NOT AND
I'M NOT
THE CIVIC WEEK TALKING TO THIS
TEST RANGE IN GENERAL WITH WITH
TESTING YOU YOUR CONCERN WITH.
VALIDITY AND RELIABILITY AND
SOMETIMES THAT'S HARD TO CONTROL
WHEN YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS.
GRADING TESTS AS OPPOSED TO OF
COURSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
THAT FOLKS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
ACTIVELY FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
IN TERMS OF INVOLVING TEACHERS
MORE IN THE IN THE GRADING
ASSESSING OF EXAMS BUT IT IS IT
IS THE COMPLEXITY I I UNDERSTAND
THAT AND. I GUESS AND I'M ALMOST
DONE HERE MISTER CHAIR I'M.
I GUESS I OF MY UNDERSTANDS THEY
ARE GREAT PART OF IT.
SERVER GONNA READ PART OF IT ONE
OF THE GREAT ALL THAT.
THAT'S I THINK A QUESTION THAT
SHOULD UNANSWERED LONG BEFORE
THEY WENT OUT TO A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR BUT THAT. WE DON'T I
DON'T NEED YOU TO RESPOND IF YOU
KNOW HOW TO DEAL HAS A VITAL
INFORMATION
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION ON THE TIMELINE.
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COMPUTERIZED VERSION EVEN IF WE
HAVEN'T ALL PACKED THAT'S NOT
COMPUTERIZED.
AND ALSO.
WHAT IS THE ROLE THE PRIVATE
CONTRACT WHAT IS THE ROLE THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER?
IN IN THE OPAC VERSES THE SELF.
THANK YOU.
I'M DONE.
OKAY TRIPS PREPARING LABOR HERE.
I WANTED TO IT TO GO TO THE
EARLY AT SECTION REAL QUICK.
AND. WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
OUR REQUESTS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
YEAH EXPENDED SIGNIFICANT ANNA
MONEY IN EARLY ADD NEWS THAT THE
BILLION DOLLAR.
NUMBER THROWN OUT THERE AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I LEFT
WILL CONSIDER IT BUT ONE PIECE
THAT WE THINK IS.
.
IS THAT IS THIS REALLY GREAT IN
THE TABLE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
FEDERAL MONEY THROUGH THAT
THROUGH THE LATEST CONGRESSIONAL
BUDGET.
ACTION.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA AND IN
THE. CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT TONIGHT I DON'T SEE IT
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLAN SO. WHAT IF YOU
COULD A PINE ABOUT THAT
AND?
?
YOU GO FIRST SHARPLY OUT OF
FRIENDS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
FORTUNATELY WE WERE UNABLE TO
YOU I T. IN THE FINAL FEDERAL
AUGMENTATION FOR CCTV DE. IN
TIME TO MAKE IT AND TV AD MAYOR
VISION. HOWEVER WE DO THINK THAT
MORE TIME IS NEEDED IN ORDER TO
FULLY FLESHED OUT A PROPOSAL AYE
AS TO HOW TO SPEND THIS THIS
AUGUST WANT HIM AUGMENTATION. AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T HAVE FULL
FEDERAL GUIDANCE AS TO ANY RULES
OR REGULATIONS THAT THESE THAT
AUGMENTATION AND I WILL NEED TO
ADHERE TAIL. AND ALSO WERE NOT
CURRENTLY FULLY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CITY BE G. AS THE LAW
CURRENTLY STANDS.
AS WE THINK THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER AS WE
AYE DEVELOP A PROPOSAL AS TO HOW
TO SPEND THE ONE TEN FIVE. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT I PUBLIC
COMMENT ES DE CLEAN KITCHEN
PROCESS WOULD BE.
A A BUT BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE
OF WE DECIDE HOW TO SPEND THESE
BUTTONS
LABOR HAVING PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
FOR SIX MONTHS ON THE. NUMBER OF
FAMILIES THAT ARE IN NEED N
KIDS TRYING TO GET INTO QUALITY
CHILDCARE AND EARLY PRE K.
PROGRAMS AND SO. IF IF WE
APPROPRIATED. OF THOSE DOLLARS.
FOR THOSE PURPOSES THEM THE
EXPANSION OF THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA PROGRAMS
THAT. WOULD THAT BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT THAT.
CONGRESSIONAL PLAN LAID OUT FOR
STATES TO US TO LOOK AT. AT THIS
BUT WE DON'T HAVE FULL FEDERAL
GUIDANCE AS TO WHAT THE RULES
ARE GOING TO BE REGARDING THE
FUNDS SO WE FEEL IT'S TOO EARLY
TO MAKE ANY. DECISIONS AS TO
WHAT WHAT IT WOULD NOT BE
APPLICABLE. FAIR ENOUGH.
DID DID LA ALL HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
ON THAT I AM. OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND TERMS OF USE OF THE FUNDS AS
THAT. OF THE REGULAR. BLOCK
GRANT RULES APPLY.
BUT YOU ALSO NEED TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE REGULAR
RULES AND CALIFORNIA A FEW YEARS
AGO WAS FOUND NOT TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE NO NO STATE WAS IN
COMPLIANCE BECAUSE THEY HAD JUST
CHANGED THE RULES AND THE
FEDERAL RULES ARE NOW MUCH MORE
STRINGENT FOR EXAMPLE DOING
ANNUAL. INSPECTIONS RATHER THAN
INSPECTIONS PERIODICALLY WHEN
COMPLAINTS AROSE SO I THINK THE
BIG DEBATE IS OUR UNDERSTANDING
AS YOU VERY LIKELY COULD USE
THAT FOR SLOTS FOR RATES FOR
TRAINING. FOR MAYBE EVEN
FACILITIES.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY NEED TO BE
MAKING YOU GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO
DO WHAT THE FUNDS WOULD LIKE IF
THEY HAD DONE A FINE BUT THEY
REALLY DID WANT YOU TO DO
SOMETHING MORE WITH INSPECTIONS.
OR OR NOT DO THINGS WITH LICENSE
EXEMPTS YOU MIGHT NEED TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES ON THOSE AREAS. BUT
IT'S A GREAT THING TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WE KNOW WE'RE
GONNA AS A STATE GET MORE MONEY
SUBSTANTIALLY IN BOTH THE STE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND NEXT YEAR
SO TO BE THINKING ABOUT WITHIN
THOSE BROAD PARAMETERS WHAT
YOU'RE HIGHS PRODUCE WOULD BE.
OKAY.
TODD. HOW QUICK JUMP REAL QUICK
TO CT  I KNOW MR O'DONNELL
TALKS ABOUT IT SO WE WE HAD A?
LENGTHY HEARING ABOUT THIS
TWICE.
AND.
ARE TWO ISSUES WERE WHERE THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND DONE AND THE.
AT THE LOCATION WHETHER IT'S
THAT THAT THE NEW PROPOSAL OR
GOING BACK TO CD.
IT'S I KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS LOOKING AT THAT AND
SO. DON'T ASK CD .
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS MEETS.
THE SUGGESTION THAT YOU LAID
OUT EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
AS FAR AS THE IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THE OVERSEER OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM YEAH SO.
I GUESS NO I MEAN THAT'S
GENERALLY WHAT SO MUCH OF MY
COMMENTS WERE I MEAN WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE.
THE THE EFFORT.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WE STILL THINK.
ESSENTIALLY WE THINK WHERE WE
WOULD BE BETTER POSITIONED TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM.
YEAH
AND DO YOU THINK THAT IF WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT MORE RESOURCES.
ON THE TABLE FOR THIS THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO YEAH EXPAND ACCESS TO CT
THREE DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ARE I WOULD EXPECT
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS PROBABLY
YES BUT I NEED A PRIDE NEED TO
DOUBLE CHECK.
FAIR ENOUGH.
MUSLIM MONTH.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE I
HAVE SPECIFICALLY WITH THE AD
THE FEDERAL. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT I
GUESS.
.
AS A MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND REFLECT ON THE FACT
THAT FOR. OF OF THE LONG PERIOD
OF TIME WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
AN INCREASE.
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD AND CHILD.
.
CARE. AND.
I AM NOT.
I AM NOT CLEAR.
WHY THE CHOICES BEING MADE TO
HOLD
EXISTING PROGRAMS?
SO I SAY I THINK YOUR QUESTIONS
ALLUDING TO WHY WE'RE NOT
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL TELL THEM
OUT AGAIN AS AS A MAJOR EARLIER
IS REALLY A MATTER OF NOT HAVING
A A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
ALL OF THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
ARE. A GOING TO BE ATTACHED TO
THAT TO THOSE AT THAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT.
AND AND AGAIN NOT BEING IN
PHILLY FULLY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CCTV G. REGULATIONS AS THEY
CURRENTLY STAND AND WHAT IS THE
TIMELINE FOR THAT.
TO BECOME FULLY IN COMPLIANCE
TO FULLY UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
SAYING YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE COMPLIANCE ASK REQUIREMENTS
ARE SO WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR
YOU. TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION TO
MAKE THAT ASSESSMENT SURE THREE
WE DO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RULES
REGULATIONS ARE IN TERMS OF CCTV
COMPLIANCE I THINK WHAT WHAT AT
MY MY POINT IS WE DON'T HAVE
FULL FEDERAL GUIDANCE AS TO. THE
SPECIFIC AND RULES THAT WILL
WILL BE ATTACHED TO THIS THIS
ONETIME AUGMENTATION SO WHAT IS
THE TIMELINE FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THE FEDERAL RULES TO.
FOR THIS ONE TIME AUGMENTATION
SO.
WE WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT
WE GREAT WE'VE BEEN GATHERING
INFORMATION THROUGHOUT THE
SPRING AND THEN BRADEN.
WE WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE AYE CLOSELY IN
ORDER THAT TO DETERMINE WHAT
RULES THAT KIND OF WHAT
INFORMATION WE HAVE IS THAT
COMES UP WE ARE NOT SURE WAY AND
I FEDERAL GRANTS WILL BE
RELEASED AND WHEN WILL THAT
FUNDING HAD CALIFORNIA. I WILL
NEVER FIRST I HAVE TO DEFER TO
THE PART OF A COMPLETE BECAUSE
I'M I'M NOT SO WITH THAT TIGHTLY
AS.
I HAVE TO DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
APARTMENT HE'S AYE AND I THINK
THAT THAT DIDN'T DO WE NOW.
IT IT UNNATURAL TYPE OF THE ROAD
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER RIGHT NOW
OCTOBER FIRST SO I DON'T KNOW
IF.
THAT'S FOR THE FALL AND I WOULD
HATE TO HOLD OFF SO I'M USING IT
ON HER AND NOT YOU KNOW I SEE IT
AS AN INVESTMENT.
AND SO I GUESS THAT'S WHY MY
QUESTION START WITH WHY ARE WE
NOT MAKING THE INVESTMENT AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR AND NUMBER OF MEMBERS IN
BOTH HOUSES.
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT SO I
WANNA.
ENCOURAGE US TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT INVESTING THAT MANY.
EVEN IF IT'S ONE TIME MANY
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THE FUNDS
I'M IN THIS SPACE I WORKED AS
ONE YEAR WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
AT A TIME.
AT AND SO I THINK THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
AT AN EFFORT THAT REALLY HIGH
PRIEST MARRIOTT'S. AT FULL
CONSIDERATION IN TERMS OF. OF
YOU FAST IMPLEMENTATION
INVESTMENT.
AND IF A FIVE MIGHT CLARIFY A OF
THE ARE INTENT HERE IS NOT TO
NOT USE THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
LATE AUGMENTATION BUT RATHER
JUST IT TO HOLD OFF AND IN ORDER
TO HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF. OF THE RULES REGULATIONS
WITH
SO DO YOU THINK YOU'LL USE IT AN
ACADEMIC YEAR YEAH EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN A WERE REALLY SUCKS
MOST OF THE TIME LINE.
BUT IT GO THROUGH A
SUPPLEMENTARY DEL PROCESS OR BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET WHERE.
WHERE OPEN TO DISCUSSING?
TENANTS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAVEZ.
I THINK THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WITH THE FEDERAL.
IS THAT DAD THEY DEAL WITH A
DIFFERENT FISCAL YEAR THAN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THERE FISCAL YEAR STARTS IN
OCTOBER WERE OURS.
SO THEY DO THE BUDGET CYCLE
DEFINITELY USE THAT THE PROBLEM.
THAT IT'S CRACKED.
THE EVAN.
I'M ONE OF WEIGH IN ON THE ISSUE
OF EARLY CHILD EDUCATION
DISRUPTING HAS BEEN IMPORTANT TO
THE REPUBLICANS. FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
SO AS YOU GO BACK AND WORK ON
THIS WITH THE FEDERAL ARE YOU
FOR GOING HOW WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS.
ABOUT WE WANT TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR EARLY CHALLENGE
OCCASION. I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISCUSSION I'VE
HAD THIS WITH THE GOVERNOR FEW
TIMES ON YOU KNOW.
THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IN THINGS
LIKE THAT. BUT UGH WILL LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
NAM FIGURE FIVE OF THE.
KELLY  REPORT.
IT TALKS ABOUT THE FEDERAL
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY
FAMILIES.
GONE FROM THREE EIGHTY NINE TO.
MAY REVISE AS THREE THIRTY LAS
A.
FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
WHAT?
IS THAT WHY WAS THAT REDUCE
SHOULD YOU NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
HELLO.
I'M HERE FIGURE FIVE.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU CAN YOU POINT
YOUR WHERE YEAH YEAH I'M SORRY
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I AM I'M
SORRY.
WORKING TNF IS USED ENTIRELY
FOR STAGE ONE CHILD CARE IN AND
SO IT BECOMES INVOLVED IN HOUSE
STAGE ONE IS FUNDED WHICH AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AS. PART OF THE
SINGLE COUNTY ALLOCATION.
SO I THINK IT'S MUCH MORE
CONNECTED WITH WHAT'S HPPENING
TO OVERALL CAO WORKS
CASELOAD WHICH IS DECLINING FROM
JANUARY TO MAY OVERALL CAL WORKS
CASELOAD AND THE CHILD
ASSOCIATED STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
IS PROBABLY GONE DOWN SUCH THAT.
THE WAY THE STATE TRADITIONALLY
BUDGETS THAT IS YOU STAND UP
JUST FOR THAT PARTICULAR STAGE.
SO I THINK IT'S MORE OF A
MECHANICAL ADJUSTMENT FOR HOW WE
ASSESS.
FUNDS STREAMS ACROSS THE
PROGRAMS AND AS A STATE WE'VE
JUST CHOSEN TO USE THAT FOR
STAGE ONE.
AS FOR I THOUGHT BECAUSE OF MY
UNDERSTANDING.
THERE'S A POT.
HUMAN RESOURCES AND PART OF
EDUCATION USE AND I WAS
WONDERING HAS BEEN SHIFTED OVER
THERE AWAY FROM.
THIS
POT IS THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
HALF FOR MANY YEARS VAST BULK OF
TANNA FRANCE GONE TO STAGE ONE I
THINK THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE YEARS WHERE SLIVER WAS
USED FOR STATES TO. BATES.
SO YOU ARE TALKING AB PART OF
FINANCE WHERE THE MONEY WENT.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT THE STAGE
ONE ALLOCATION AFTER TO FIRE AT
YOU MAY SOCIAL SERVICES
COLLEAGUES UP ON THAT.
OKAY I'M. ON TO ANOTHER AREA OF
INTEREST TO ME.
IN NOT ESPECIALLY THE REPUBLIC
CAUCUS IN AS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THE.
I'M LOOKING AT THE SHEET WAS
GIVEN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE FRONT PAGE FIGURE FOR YES.
AND I'M TRYING TO FIND SHE G. E.
IN HERE.
AND I DON'T SEE IT NOW I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A CHANGE.
FROM WHAT WE ORIGINALLY HAD SHE
KEY WAS DISCUSSED BEFORE IS SHE
TEAM EBAY IMPOSTER ANYMORE. WHAT
WE DON'T IT?
SO I IT IT'S LISTED AS K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM IN ITS
TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS UNDER THE ONGOING.
IT'S YOUR THIRD ITEM DOWN IN THE
ON GOING K. TWELVE SECTIONS TO
HER FOURTEEN MILLION TOTAL.
MMHM.
SO OUR PROPOSAL IS NOT NURSES AT
A AND WERE WERE WORKING IT AND
IT'S QUIRK CALLING THAT THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM IT'S
GREAT TECHNICAL EDUCATION BUT IT
HAS A DIFFERENT FOCUS THEN.
WHEN.
FOR THERE IS TWO MILLION THAT
THAT THE CLEAN MILLIONS THE
ADDITION BECAUSE.
THAT IS THE ADDITION OF US SOME
PAYMENTS TO GO TO THE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA IT'S FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
SO THE NUMBER WE HAD DISCUSSED
BEFORE WAS A LOT BIGGER THAN TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IT WAS YEAH THAT
THEY THEY COMMITTEE YEAH WE WE
SUGGESTED A HIGHER NUMBER AND
CHANGING THE.
.
THE ADMINISTRATION FROWNED.
WE ARE GOING BACK TO WHERE IT
HAS BEEN LAST YEAR'S AND IN CD.
SO I HAD TO CHARGE THAT BECAUSE
I WAS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION WEEKS
BUDGET WAS SIGNED ON TO THAT.
NOW WAIT I GUESS TO FORTY TWO
ONE OF FOURTEEN MILLION RICE THE
TUNER FOURTEEN IS THE AMOUNT
THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
RIGHT AND WE WANTED HIGHER
NUMBER AND SO THE GOVERNOR'S
WILL NOT THIS NUMBER IS THAT
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THAT'S
CORRECT.
BURNETT FOR NOW.
SO WE'RE IN AGREEMENT THAT WE'RE
GOING BACK AND PUSH IN ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND SEEKING
EASE I. JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT.
AND THERE WAS ONE OTHER AREA.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL GRANTS.
.
IN THE HOLISTIC VIEW.
I'M TO BRING EVERYBODY
APPARENTLY.
IT'S GOT A.
I'M THE NICE GUY BY THE WAY.
IS MY LAST HEARING YEAH.
SO WE COULD CHARTER SCHOOL
GRANT.
.
IS IT A PLUS UP OR DOWN OVERALL
AND ALL THE MOVEMENT IN NUMBERS
AND.
THAT TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING AND
THEN.
CHARTER SCHOOL OFFICIALLY GRANT
PROGRAM AUGMENTATION.
I WOULD BE MORE FUNDING FOR BOTH
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN UNDER THE MY REVISION
MORE FUNDING YASSER IT WOULD GO
UP UNDER THE MAYOR OF VISION
TWENTY ONE MILLION AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. AND THEY ARE THE HOW
TO PROPOSAL IT WOULD GO ON
TWENTY I AM FIVE MILLION IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS MORE.
AND I'M GOING ON TWENTY FIVE W.
SAID I'M SORRY.
YA SO THERE WOULD BE OTHER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS RUNNING A
SHORTFALL SO THEY WOULD PROVIDE
THE TWENTY ONE MILLION TO BACK
FILL AND THEN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION YES AND THE WAY YOU'RE
SCORING AT JUST THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWENTY ONE AND THE
TWENTY FIVE. FOUR MILLION YEAR
OVER YEAR YEAH PLAY YAHTZEE ALL
THE TIME OUT AGAIN THAT REALLY
QUICK WITH THE NUMBERS.
SO.
.
IS THAT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS.
NO WE DON'T THINK IF YOU WANTED
TO FUND THE HIGHER MAXIMUM AWARD
NO I THINK WE'RE PRETTY
CONFIDENT IT'LL FALL SHORT.
I I DEPARTMENT FINANCIERS SHIRTS
EARNED BECAUSE I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR IS A BIG SUPPORTER
DRIVERS GOAL SO. CHAIR SURELY
GAP THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
THE WAY THAT WE CAME UP WITH
THIS CALCULATION WAS OUT WE WORK
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
SCHOOL FINANCE AUTHORITY WHO
ADMINISTERS THE PROGRAM. AND
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
DETERMINING HOW THE BEHAVIOR IS
I'M ON THE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
HOW THEY'RE REACTING TO THIS NEW
POLICY ITS WRITER SINK THE WAY
AT THE ALLEY O..
CALCULATED THE POLICY IS IF.
EVERYBODY THEY IN HIS.
ALL OF THE EIGHTY A IN THE
CURRENT PROGRAM TIMES THAT BY
THE HIGHEST GRANT AMOUNT NOW WE
KNOW BASED ON PARTICIPATION THAT
ONLY ABOUT.
FORTY PERCENT ACTUALLY GET
THE HIGHEST GRANT AMOUNT SO IF
WE WERE TO GO WITH THE ALLEY OF
NUMBER OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO MILLION. THAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE OVER APPROPRIATING THE
PROGRAM AND THEREFORE WE GET THE
SAVINGS IN THE PROGRAM. MOVING
FORWARD SO OUR APPROACH IS TO
USE OUR OUR BEST ESTIMATES BASED
ON BEHAVIOR THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
CURRENT YEAR THAT ADJUSTING TO
THE CURRENT ONTO THE NEW POLICY
AS THE BUDGET ACT. AND THEN
MOVING FORWARD ADDICT USING NOT
FUNDING AS A BASE AND THEN WITH
THE COLA. DRINK OUR DIFFERENCES
ACTUALLY ARE ARE MUCH MORE
STRAIGHT FORWARD I THINK THAT
THEY ASSUME NO ATTENDANCE GROWTH
OR VERY LITTLE ATTENDANCE GROW
SOMETHING LIKE ONE PERCENT YEAR
OVER YEAR. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ACTUAL ATTENDANCE GROWTH CHARTER
SCHOOL ADA SCORED IN THIS
PROGRAM IS BEEN MORE LIKE
FIFTEEN PERCENT ON AVERAGE
SO WE USE LIKE A THREE YEAR
ROLLING AVERAGE TO RUN OUR
ESTIMATE FOR THE BUDGET YEAR AND
I THINK THEY HOLD IT FLAT.
BUT THIS NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THE EIGHTY A IS WHAT DETERMINES
THE GRANT AND NOW IT'S MORE
LIKELY THAT THE FACILITIES COSTS
AT LEAST COSTS. ARE WHAT
DETERMINES THE GRANT AMOUNT THE
PARTICIPATION THE PROGRAM.
HEAVILY IS FUNDED ON FACILITIES
AND LEASE COST RATHER THAN
EIGHTY A SHARON THIS IS WAY TOO
TACKY BUT WE LOOK AT LEAST COST
TO THESE ARE LIVE LIKE BEING
DRIVERS EIGHTY AND LEASE COSTS
AND LEAST COSTS GO UP ON AVERAGE
ABOUT SIX PERCENT A YEAR.
FINANCE HOUSING TAPPED TO THE
LEAST COST UNDER THEIR PROPOSAL
AT THE KEY TWELVE COLA AND WE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT AS WELL. SO
ACTUALLY ACCOUNT THAT LEASE
COSTS WILL NOT GROW AS MUCH AS
THEY HAVE TRADITIONALLY BECAUSE
OF THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
IT'LL BE CAPPED AT MORE LIKE
THREE RATHER THAN SIX PERCENT SO
CAN THE BIG DRIVERS.
AND.
WELL I'M I'M WAITING TO HEAR
FROM THE CHARTER SCHOOL
COMMUNITY OUT THERE ON THIS
DISCUSSION OF WHAT SHOULD WE BE
LOOKING AT THAT. HAVE MOUNTED
STUDENTS GOING TO WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT. THE MEDIAN THE
REQUIREMENT WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
PEOPLE WE QUESTION AND
HISTORICAL LINES IN.
WE DON'T WANT OVER FUNDED SO YOU
THINK YOU'RE FUNDING IT IS FULL
NAY. THE LA O. DISAGREES
SO.
I DON'T.
LATER ON IN THE TESTIMONY HOPE
WILL HAVE SOME DETAILS WHAT THEY
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE FOR LET
ME ASK THOSE THREE AREAS WE CARE
ABOUT IS CHARTER SCHOOLS. EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND CT.
WELL THANK YOU.
AND THAT WILL SAVE ME HERE
FAREWELL FOR THE FINAL HEARING A
COUPLE DAYS.
YEAH BUT WE KNOW WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK IN AND.
AS YOU SAID EARLIER YOU KNOW
THIS IS OUR IDEA TO MARINATE
THESE IDEAS PROPOSALS AND COME
UP WITH THEIR OWN PLAN FROM A
COUPLE DAYS SO.
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE AT THE TAKE ROLL
REAL QUICK.
MCCARTY HERE CHVEZ. HERE AMONG.
MEDINA.
FIRST CITY. O'DONNELL HERE.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE THAT
CONCLUDES THE OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE.
PROPOSALS FOR CAPE OF AN EARLY
HEAD WE'RE NOT GOING TO PROCEED
WITH. PUBLIC COMMENTS.
IT COULD BE.
SO PLEASE LINE AT FIRST WE WANT
TO BRING UP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
I THINK SHE'S GOING TO BE JOINED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THEY ADMIT.
DO YOU WANNA WAITED GO.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN.
OKAY YEAH WE CAN WAIT.
THE. THAT'S OKAY SO IT SO WE CAN
HAVE AND IN THE INTERIM PEOPLE
BEHIND YOU GO.
THAT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE INCREASES
THAT WERE SEEN TO LC FF FROM.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CERTIFICATION
IS A MAJOR PRIORITY FOR US AND
WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
FINAL LANGUAGE.
AND WOULD LIKE TO ENSURE IT
MEETS ALL THE GOALS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BY DOWN THIS IS A
MAJOR PRIORITY FOR US MORE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THOSE SMALL FOR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BELIEVES
HE WITH THAT VOICE HAVE WANTED
TO UNDERSCORE SUPPORT FOR THE
NOTION OF BECOMING MORE PARENT
FRIENDLY AND TRANSPARENCY IN.
THE DETAILS MATTER HERE WE'D
LIKE TO BE AVAILABLE TO. YOU AND
YOUR STAFF TO WORK EVEN FURTHER
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHICH
IS. A MARGINAL IMPROVEMENT FROM
JANUARY.
ALSO WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE'S IT LOOKS TO BE A HUGE
OMISSION OF LEGISLATIVE
OPPORTUNITY WHICH IS A SEVEN
PERCENT SET ASIDE AND ESTHER.
STATE FEDERAL FUNDS WHICH IS
ANYWHERE FROM THAT STORY FEDERAL
FUNDS COMING TO THE STATE AND
STATE SET ASIDE AUTHORITY OF IT
NEARLY HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THERE. IS.
SHOULD SAM GONNA BE SPENT
SOMEHOW BUT WITHOUT YOUR
OVERSIGHT IN THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BUT THE PART NUMBER
HALF OF THE STATE'S EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION COALITION. I'M SO
RECOGNIZING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
AND WERE ALSO ONLY SERVING
FOURTEEN PERCENT OF ELIGIBLE. ON
INFANTS AND TODDLERS THE
COALITION IS JOINING THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
ASKING FOR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
BABIES.
SO THIS INVESTMENT WILL PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE ACCESS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND WILL INCREASE THE
INFANTILE ADJUSTMENT FACTOR TO
FULLY COVER THE COST OF CARING
FOR OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN.
WERE ALSO REQUESTING ONE TIME
INVESTMENT INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION. FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT STARTUP GRANTS AND
TO INCREASE THE CHILD CARE.
INITIATIVE PROJECT TO FURTHER
RECRUIT PROVIDERS AND CHARLIE
LEARNING SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
FAIR ABOUT JUST WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS THAT WE
SUPPORT ANY EFFORT TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WE SUPPORT THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE TEN THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN.
PROCESS WERE STILL REVIEWING THE
UPDATE PROCESS AND WE'RE ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONE TIME
RESOURCES BECAUSE THAT DOES GO
TO ALL LEDS DESPITE. THEIR
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS THROUGH
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
FOR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE. AND FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION AS YOU
CONSIDER MAYBE RICK DIVERTING
FUNDS FOR OTHER PURPOSES PLEASE
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE STILL HAVE
AND APPLY ONLINE ARE FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS IN CAMP YOU. AMERICAN YOU
DON'T SECOND SOMEONE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE DR SUSAN EGGMAN CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS BUDGET REQUEST.
OUR ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
BABIES ASK WILL DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF SLOTS AVAILABLE
INCREASE STATES RATES FOR INFANT
AND TODDLER CARE. CREATE A NEW
GRANT PROGRAM TO FUND
IMPLEMENTATION AND START UP
COSTS OF NEW CHILDCARE
FACILITIES. AND ESTABLISH A FUND
TO RECRUIT A NEW GENERATION OF
FAMILY CARE PROVIDERS.
A SECOND REQUEST FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
HIGHLIGHTING THE ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM IS COMING
AS WELL. IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE
GET THE BILLION FOR BABIES
FUNDING BECAUSE THE INFANT TO
TODDLER AGE GROUP IS WHEN
FAMILIES STRUGGLE THE MOST TO
FIND CARE. WHEN CARE IS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE AND WHERE THE STATE
HAS LAGGED IN REINVESTMENT SINCE
THE DEVASTATING CUTS DURING THE
RECESSION THANK YOU.
BUT IN THE MORNING I WILL NOT
REPEAT WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID
BUT I THINK JUST TO REITERATE I
DON'T I'M SURE THERE'S NOT ONE
OF YOU THAT WHO SET UP THERE WHO
DON'T THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR. A HIKE FOR KIDS TO HAVE
APPROPRIATE CHILDCARE WE ALL
KNOW THE RESEARCH ON A ZERO
THREE AND BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
AND HOW HOW IT COSTS ARE THE
BILLION DOLLARS IT WILL INVEST
NOW WILL BE ABLE TO TO MAKE.
CHILD BE ABLE HAVE A LIFETIME
OF PRODUCTIVITY AND SUCCESS NOT
JUST FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. THAT WERE JUST
OUT TALKING ABOUT ISSUES ARE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND WE KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES A KID TO A GROWING UP
IN IN NOW AIR AREAS ARE THEY
REALLY NEED THIS KIND OF
INVESTMENT. A BECAUSE WE NEED TO
INCREASE AS MANY PROTECTIVE
FACTORS AS WE CAN BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE WORLD AS IT CONTINUES
TO GROW WILL NEED ALL OF THEIR
SKILLS TO BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THROUGH. UP AND MAKE THE BEST
CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES.
WOMEN SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN
GO TO WORK OR KEEP A JOB UP
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNSURE ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THEIR CHILDREN. A SO
THIS IS THE KIND OF REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK. THAT WE NEED.
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE INCREASED
THE MINIMUM WAGE WHICH HAS
REDUCED THE NUMBER OF SLOTS A
AND AGAIN I KNOW WE'RE PREACHING
TO THE CHOIR BUT WE JUST HAD A
RESPECT. UP TO THE COMMITTEE AND
OUT OF RESPECT TO THE MILLIONS
OF WOMEN IN THOUSANDS OF WOMEN
WHO WERE ARE HER WAITING FOR
THIS. AND THAT WERE ABLE TO
REINVEST IT IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
GROUND LEVEL AS WE CONTINUE TO
RAISE THE WHOLE STATE THING OKAY
MARKETING GAUGE IF YOU REAL
QUICK. PERSON REMEMBER LIMON.
THANK YOU I A N. THINK BOTH AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR SPEAKING ON
THIS ISSUE I THINK IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OVER A DOZEN.
BIPARTISAN WOMEN IN BOTH HOUSES
MEMBERS IN BOTH HOUSES AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR DECADES AND THIS
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'S BRAND NEW
AND I THINK THAT IT IS ABOUT AN
INVESTMENT THE WORD INVESTMENT.
WAS USED ON AND WE KNOW THAT
EARLY INVESTMENT YIELDS LONG
TERM RESULTS FOR STUDENTS I WANT
TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR BRINGING
IT UP AND I HOPE THAT TODAY'S
CONVERSATION WE ECHO THAT THIS
IS. A VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR A BODY OF INDIVIDUALS HERE
AS THERE ARE FOR MANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUPPORT THIS I'M
BUT I DON'T WANT IT TO BE LOST
ON US OUT THAT WE ARE AT THIS.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR ASKING.
AND AND NOT WE DON'T GET THE
ASKS.
ANY OF THE YEARS ON AND WE HOPE
THAT THIS ASK.
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL GET US
TO A LONG TERM GOAL AND THAT YOU
KNOW IN THE FUTURE DOESN'T HAVE
TO HAPPEN ON A YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS THAT WE CAN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT IT
WILLTAKE TO MAKE THE NEEDED.
LONG
TERM INVESTMENT.
YES I DID BUT YES SIR MISTER
VOEPEL.
THIS IS A FRIENDLY RESPECTFUL
QUESTION.
BUT A BILLION DOLLARS FOR BABIES
RAIMES AND IT'S VERY NICE OKAY I
GET IT.
HOW COME A BILLION?
WHAT ABOUT A HALF A BILLION?
WHAT NUMBER?
WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE.
THE THE BUDGET OVER OVER TIME
HAS TO AS WE WENT INTO THE
RECESSION THAT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS THAT WAS REDUCED.
I'VE.
AND WE OFTEN SAY THAT THAT.
BUDGETS ARE A REFLECTION OF OF
VALUES
AND THIS WILL OPEN AGAIN WHEN
THERE WAS NO MONEY WE'RE CUTTING
POLICE EVERYBODY ELSE.
CHILDCARE WAS WAS CUT DOWN TO TO
LONELINESS.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO RETURN
TO THOSE NUMBERS AT THIS WILL
GET US THERE AND THEN WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA INVESTMENT.
A SO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR THE MOON WERE ASKING
FOR WHAT WAS LOST AND WITH THE
COST OF LIVING WHAT CONTINUES TO
RISE.
AND AS YOU KNOW WE WERE WHEN WE
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE IT ALSO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF SLOTS.
WE JUST KNOW THERE ARE THE
BACKLOG WE ALL HAD CHILDREN.
UP IN OUR OFFICES LAST WEEK
TALKING ABOUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
SLOTS FOR CHILDCARE AND AGAIN
WE'RE ASKING MORE MORE PEOPLE TO
GO OUT TO WORK.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE SO A
BILLION A BILLION WILL JUST
COVER THOSE COSTS AND BE ABLE TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT EXTRA FOR
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD TO KNOW.
THANK YOU AND AND I WANT TO
ALLUDE TO THAT AND ASK A
QUESTION AS WELL AT THE FIRST IS
ON SOMETIMES GET REPORTS FROM
DEPARTMENT FINDS THAT THAT SHOWS
THAT WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN EASY LAST YEAR'S
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
THOSE ARE FOR THINGS LIKE RATES
AND SLOTS BUT IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE THE UNDERLYING ISSUE THAT
DURING THE RECESSION.
CUT SO MUCH OF ACCESO THAT
BILLION DOLLAR CUT DOESN'T EQUAL
THE MONEY WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
BACK ON OF THE.
UNDER THE ON THE THE EQUATION
HERE A LARGE PART BECAUSE COST
INCREASES AND SO FORTH SO. SO
THIS REQUEST WOULD.
WOULD ROUGHLY GET US BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE WHICH WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WHO ARE. ELIGIBLE AND.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT NEED TO TO
HELP YOU KNOW.
MAHMOUD FAMILY MEMBER GET BACK
TO WORK AND ALSO MAKE SURE THE
YOUNGSTER HOUSES HAS A CHANCE
FOR A SUCCESSFUL FUTURE SO I'M
WERE IN. FULL ACCORD YEAR EARLY
EDUCATION MATTERS WE WANT TO
DOUBLE DOWN.
THIS YEAR MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
THAT I KNOW I HAVE NINE YEAR
OLDS AND THERE MIGHT BE THESE
AND YOU HAVE A I THINK IN NINE
OR TEN ON YOUR SEIZE YOUR BABY
TOO. SO WHAT WE CONSIDER BABIES
ARE RECONSIDERING UP TO ZERO
THROUGH FIVE ARE WE ARE WE
LOOKING AT JUST INCIDENT TALLER
BECAUSE WORD AT THE COMMITTEE
LOOKING AT ALL THOSE ISSUES
FROM.
FROM FROM EARLY EDUCATION
THROUGH OUR STATE A PREPAID
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS IMPOTENT
TALLER ACCESS AND STATE
CHILDCARE PROGRAM WE PRIMARILY
WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THIS IS FROM
ZERO TO THREE YEARS OLD. I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY GOES LONGER THAN THAT
BUT THE ISSUE IS THAT MANY OF
OUR INFANTS WE DON'T HAVE A
PLACE TO TAKE THEM MANY
PRESCHOOLS WILL NOT TAKE A CHILD
THAT HAS NOT BEEN POTTY TRAINED.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THOSE CHILDREN IN A REALLY
RELIABLE. OF SETTING AND.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
ABSOLUTELY DO THAT.
I KNOW I'M A GRANDMOTHER AND MY
DAUGHTER CAN'T FIND A CURE.
SHE LIVES IN LOS ANGELES.
CALLS ME IN TEARS AND TO SIGN UP
FOR DAYCARE IT'S.
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS HER
REGISTRATION AND AFTER SHE'S
FILLED OUT THE FORM THEY SAY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OPENINGS.
SO IT'S BECOME VERY VERY
DIFFICULT AND SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO FIND ANY KIND OF
DAYCARE. AND I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD.
NOT PREVENT A FAMILY FROM BEING
WHOLE AND MAKING SURE WE GET
THESE KIDS IN A RELIABLE CALLED.
EDUCATION.
SETTING SURE SO THAT YES THIS IS
FOR THE. FOR FOR PROBE BEFORE
THEY START SCHOOL BASICALLY AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO OF COURSE ASKS
FOR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
YEAH.
WE'RE GETTING THERE AND AND ONE
THING THAT WE'RE GOING TO ON TO
LOOK AT TO. IS THAT YOU KNOW
THIS OF COURSE IS JUST FOR
INCOME ELIGIBLE FAMILIES BUT YOU
CAN ALL OF OUR DISTRICT YOU
COULD BE. MAKING SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A
FAMILY LET'S SAY A CAREER FOR
AND BY NO MEANS ARE YOU WEALTHY
BY KNOWN BY NO MEANS CAN YOU
AFFORD AND YOU'RE AND YOU'RE
NOT.
POOR ENOUGH TO AFFORD. THE
TEASER A PROGRAMS THAT WE OFFER
AND SO. THERE'S THERE'S THIS
MISSING MIDDLE PIECE OF
ELIGIBILITY IS THAT'S ONE THING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ADDRESSING
ESPECIALLY IN OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL ELIGIBILITY. THINGS UP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR POP
PRESENTATION AND CERTAINLY THIS
IS THAT.
THE TOP THE LIST FOR OUR FINAL
ACTION THANK YOU VERY MAKES YOU
VERY LINK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION. AND.
WE DO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM.
WE THINK THAT.
CERTAINLY THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL. AND THE
DIALOGUE THAT WE HEARD A FEW
MINUTES AGO BETWEEN THE LA WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCE I THINK EXEMPLIFIES THE
FACT THAT. THE TIMING OF THIS.
PROGRAM.
IS SUCH THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS
KNOW EXACTLY THE NUMBERS IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
AND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ATTEMPTS TO TRUE UP IN MAY.
WHAT THE ACTUAL NUMBERS ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE?
TREASURER'S OFFICE SPEND A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME TRYING TO
KIND OF FIGURE OUT THE NUMBERS.
GOING FORWARD AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT WE THINK THIS
IDEA OF CHEWING UP EVERY MAY IS
PROBABLY THE RIGHT WAY TO GO SO
WE ACTUALLY DO GET THE RIGHT
NUMBER.
WE DO ALSO HOWEVER AGREE WITH
ALL OF THE LA NO ABOUT.
THEY MAKE SOME SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SHOULD TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY TO THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. IN TERMS OF
ACCIDENT COST THAT MIGHT COME UP
IN THAT ONE I WAS EXPECTED AND
WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD PROPOSAL
THAT WE SUPPORT FROM THE LA OUT
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING KIMONO WITH
CHILDREN NOW AND A PART OF THE
EEC COALITIONS CONTACT OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ASK.
OF THE BILLION FOR BABIES.
THE ACCESS.
EXPANSION OF SLOTS BUT
PARTICULARLY ALSO THAT THE
SUPPORTS FOR PROVIDERS TO REALLY
OPEN THEIR DOORS TO MORE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS SO RACING THE
FACTOR. THINK ABOUT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAYS THE ONE TIME
GRANTS TO REALLY HELP THEM AND
SO WE CAN GO BACK TO PASS THE IN
THE STATE.
ALSO JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
ON THE QUESTION OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS NOTHING SO FAR AS
INDICATING THAT THAT.
THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE ONE
TIME.
AND THAT THEY WON'T BE PART OF
OUR ONGOING BASE AMOUNTS GOING
FORWARD SO WE NEED TO CONSIDER
THAT. AND. AS WELL AS WE AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD MEET THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
WHAT'S TO DO THERE BUT WE ALSO
THINK THEY'LL BE SOME ROOM FOR
INCREASING ACCESS WITH THOSE NEW
DOLLARS.
AND WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
SOME GUIDANCE FROM YOU AROUND
HOW THOSE DOLLARS SHOULD THE IS
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING ADAM NORTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S HOW DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION AND
WE AS WELL LIKE TO ASK OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMAN CAUCUS COMMENTS MADE HERE
TODAY. I PARTICULARLY FOR
IMPORTANT HODLER POPULATIONS
WATER AND IN MUCH NEED OF THIS
FUNDING AND THOSE INVESTMENTS
ALSO THAT IT'S REALLY SUPPORTER
FANTASTIC EASY WORKFORCE. WITH
MORE FUNDING FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES WHICH
ARE VERY MUCH NEEDED AYE WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THINK.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING THESE ARE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION ISSUE
WE.
.
SUPPORT AND APPLIED THE ARE THE
GOVERNOR FOR CONTINUING THIS
PROGRAM IN AN ONGOING WAY.
BUT WE BELIEVE THE STRUCTURE IN
MISTER O'DONNELL SPILL IS
PREFERABLE AND WE WOULD HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF BOTH FUNDING. AND.
SUPPORT FOR THE FIELD.
WOULD LOOK TO THE LANGUAGE IN
HIS BILL THANK.
THANK YOU.
JOSEPHINE ENEMY IS NOT TO KNOW
WITH CHILDREN NOW HERE BEHIND
AND BEHALF OF THE COMPANY STEM
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE TO
PROVIDE.
EARLY LEARNING.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATORS AYE
IN PRE K. THROUGH THIRD GRADE
THINKING THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CANDOR
HARRIS WITH THE NORTHERN
DIRECTORS GROUP IN CHILD ACTION
INK A WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT OF
THE EFFORTS OF LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO SUPPORT
CHILDCARE FUNDING. RIGHT THERE
WITH YOU ON A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR BABIES.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALONE WE
HAVE OVER TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
FAMILIES ON OUR WAITING LIST AND
THAT DOESN'T ENCOMPASS YOU KNOW
FAMILIES THAT ARE COBBLING
TOGETHER CHILD CARE WITH FAMILY.
FAMILIES AND OUR NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS AND ANSWERED UNCLES.
OF THESE ARE JUST THE FAMILIES
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE YOU KNOW
THROUGH OUR SUBSIDY PROGRAM BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE NEED THAT
IS BEING ON MATT AND WE NEED AS
MANY SLOTS AND AS WE CAN. SO
THANK YOU.
HELLO LARA MAGNUS STARTER WITH
COMMUNITY TELL COUNCIL OF CINEMA
COUNTY AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF NON
DIRECTORS GROUP AND AND THERE
ARE NO NETWORK.
I JUST WANT TO.
PURPOSE DOG SUPPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ASKING THE C. COALITION
SPECIALLY FOR THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
MY AGENCY HAS THIRTEEN STATE
PRESCHOOLS AND WE ARE NEVER ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING ELSE THEN CPR AND
FIRST AID RENEWAL ASKS A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SO.
THAT WOULD BE A HUGE.
A BOON FOR US TO GET MORE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THINK
IF.
GOOD MORNING CARE SINCERELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK
ECHOING ALL OF THE COMMENTS OF
ALL THOSE BEFORE ME IN ASKING
AND SUPPORTING THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ASK OF A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR BABIES. BUT REALLY
UPLIFTING THE FACT THAT.
AS YOU HELP FIND MORE SPACES
FOR FAMILIES WHO NEED HELP
PAYING FOR CHILDCARE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE SPACE FOR THEM IN
OUR IN OUR ARE NICE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE THE NUMBER ONE.
PROVIDER OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND IN HELPING.
PEOPLE START THEIR NEW FAMILY
CHILDCARE BUSINESS AND SO IN
THAT.
IN THE BILLION DOLLAR ASKED
THAT SUPPORT FOR AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REALLY
SERVES BABIES THINK THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY PRINIA WERE
FROM THE CHILD CARE LAW CENTER
ALSO IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ASK IN THE EASY EVEN BILLION FOR
BABIES.
I WANTED TO ANSWER A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP WE DO
HAVE FULL FEDERAL GUIDANCE.
ON HOW THE C. CBG MONEY SHOULD
BE SPENT THE FINAL RULES WERE
ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ON OUR DRAFT PLAN PREPRINT. ASKS
ALL THE VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND WE
ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE.
AND THE INTENT OF THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY WHICH IS NOT
ONE TIME MONEY.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ADDITIONAL
SLOTS ARE FUNDED SO I. HOPE THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE ROLL
OUT THE FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MONEY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MONEY GRIMACE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER
AND.
MACOVEI HERE TO REQUEST TO ADD
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PATHWAY TO
SUCCESS GRANT PROGRAM. ADD TO
PROVIDE BILINGUAL EDUCATION TO
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNER.
.
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
AT IN ADDITION WERE ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR THE ALPACA THANK YOU.
MORNING ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S AUGMENTATION FOR THE
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH BUTTE
COUNTY WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION WE DO THINK
THIS AUGMENTATION IS AT DESIGNED
TO FOCUS ON. SCHOOL CLIMATE SUCH
AS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
I'LL ORANGE COUNTY'S ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE.
PROPOSAL TO MOVE THIS CT
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE CHANGES
IN LANGUAGE STRENGTHENING K.
TWELVE THROW. BUT K. TWELVE
REALLY HAS THE EXPERTISE WORKING
WITH THE STUDENTS IN CT
AND THINK CD E. AND THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM IS REALLY THE
PLACE TO KEEP THE PROGRAMS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING BRED STRONG WITH
CHILDREN I WANTED TO SPEAK TO
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT WE
THINK IT'S CRITICAL. AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S AND SUPPORT FOR
THAT OR I'M PROPOSAL ON THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
INITIATIVE WE WOULD WE SUPPORT
ON FISCAL TRANSPARENCY WE
CONTINUE TO THINK MORE IS NEEDED
AND THAT THIS IS.
THAT INVENTED THAT WHICH WAS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR AND I'M
ASSISTANCE OF.
THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT BELIEVE
IT TO TRULY MEET THE NEEDS OF A
LIAISON STUDENTS FUNDING SHOULD
BE INCREASED FOR THE LEAD COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIRPERSON MCCARTY
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR STALWART
STUFF I'M ANTHEA HER TAKE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLE SOCIETY YOUR
NONPROFIT PARTNER AN OFFICIAL
STATE HISTORICAL SOCIETY. WANNA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CAREFUL
DELIBERATION TODAY ON SUCH
IMPORTANT MATTERS.
AS MS HARDMAN KNOWS WE'VE
DEVELOPED A REQUEST FOR AN
IMPACTFUL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ASK.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS FIFTEEN
FROM PROP AND NINETY EIGHT AND
TEN MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND.
THAT WE HOPE TO BRING TO YOU
SOON.
THE HISTORY CALIFORNIA CRISP
LONGS TO ALL OF US AND OUR
NARRATIVES ARE RICH AND VARIED
MAY BELONG IN OUR CLASSROOMS
WITH OUR STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
AND FAMILIES SO THAT WE CAN
UNDER. STAND THESE IMPACTFUL
pSTORIES WERE HONORED TO BE YOUR
COMPANION OF DISCOVERY IN THIS
WORK AND WERE HONORED TO BE
DEVELOPING THE TEACHING
CALIFORNIA WEBSITE ARE FREE
ONLINE PORTAL THAT WILL ALIGN
WITH THE NEW HISTORY AND SOCIAL
STUDIES FRAMEWORK THAT YOU'VE
FUNDED LAST YEAR. AND WE'RE
HUMBLED AND HONORED TO RECEIVE
STATE FUNDING THESE LAST FEW
YEARS AND HOLD THAT SACRED
PUBLIC TRUST.
IT'S OUR SINCERE HOPE OF COURSE
THAT WE MAY CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS TRUST.
AND OF PUBLIC FUNDING FOR A
PUBLIC ISSUE MISSION THANK YOU.
I'M BOB BLATTNER ON BEHALF OF
THE UNATO MISS ELK GROVE IRVINE
IN NEWPORT MESA SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASKING FOR YOUR HELP IN
EXPEDITING THE RELEASE OF BOND
FUNDS WHICH ARE SO DESPERATELY
NEEDED. BY TODAY'S KIDS WHO
WON'T HAVE A SECOND BITE AT THE
APPLE AFTER THEY GRADUATE.
MUCH IF YOU SAW ITEM SIXTY ONE
IN THE SENATE THIS MORNING WAS
APPROVED.
ASKING FOR ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION A YEAR AND HAVE
EVERYTHING CLOSED UP BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WE HAVEN'T SEEN
LANGUAGE SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES WE WOULD REALLY REALLY
HARD HARDLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING TIPPETT'S HARRIS
WERE CHILD THIRTY SIXTY. HERE TO
SUPPORT THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS DC
COALITION.
AND ALSO TO POINT OUT THAT WITH
THE SLOTS ARE WONDERFUL BUT
WITHOUT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TO READ AUGMENTATION AND QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT.
IT WON'T REALLY HAPPEN THE WAY
WE HOPE IT WILL SO PLEASE DO
FALL FOR THOSE THINGS THANK YOU.
YOU.
I WON OUT OF HOUSING DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RUN AND TSS FUNDING I'M
JUST ONE NOTE THAT WE HAVE A.
SPONSORED BILL IRAQ AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN TO REDUCE THE
USE OF SECLUSION AND RESTRAINT
IN SCHOOLS AND WE THINK THAT
THAT PROPOSAL.
I'M COMPLIMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RUN MTS US ON NOTABLY
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME REALLY
GOOD LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER
BILL AROUND.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND USE A
POSITIVE BEHAVIORAL
I'M INTERVENTIONS.
THAT THE PIECE THAT'S MISSING I
THINK OF THE DEFINITIONS AROUND
INTERVENTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
AVOIDED AND NOT USED AND HOW WE
THINK OUR BILL COMPLIMENTS.
I'M THE PROPOSAL IN THAT WAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
I GOOD MORNING WHISKEY AND WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES A WE SUPPORT.
THE UP THE REVISION ON THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND THE
M. TSS WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE BY.
FINANCING THE ADMINISTRATION ON
WITH REGARD TO THIS CLIMATE
SURVEYS WERE A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT WE ARE NOT. A BUILDING A
STATEWIDE CAPACITY FOR GETTING
THOSE.
IF SURVEYS OF THAT ARE VALID
AND RELIABLE FOR FREE OUT FOR
ALL DISTRICTS THERE ARE A LOT OF
SURVEY COMPANIES THAT ARE TRYING
TO GET DISTRICTS
TO PAY FOR THEIR SURVEYS BUT.
THEY'RE NOT ALL A GOOD PRODUCT.
OF AND WE THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE STATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT VETTING OF A MENU OF
SURVEYS.
AROUND A CAREER PREPARATION
WITH THE STATE'S BUILD OUT OF
THE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREER PREPAREDNESS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S A
FOCUS ON CAREER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE ACADEMICALLY RIGOROUS AND
THAT CAN LEAD TO POSTSECONDARY
OPPORTUNITIES. ARE AND STRONG
STUDENT SUPPORTS.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
MORE ON THAT THINK YOU.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I MY
NAME IS JENNIFER LOUIS WITH
EVELYN CLANGING ALLIANCE I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT AND WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THAT KATE WELL CITIES
STRONG WORK FIRST PROPOSAL. WE
JUST HAVE THREE POINTS FIRST WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONCUR WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL'S
COMMENTS. THAT THE K. TWELVE
GRAND SELECTION COMMITTEE WILL
DELAY THE PROCESS FOR
DISTRIBUTING FUNDS FOR TELL
LIAISE. AND WE AT THE LINK
RUNNING ALLIANCE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT POTENTIAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE PROTECTED
PARTICIPANTS WOULD HAVE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AS THEY COULD
REPRESENT DISTRICTS WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR THESE FUNDS. ARE
SECOND POINT IS ADDITIONALLY WE
WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER STRENGTHENING THE
QUALITY STANDARDS. AT THE CT
PROGRAM APPLICANTS AS TO ENSURE
THAT STEVEN OPPORTUNITIES ARE
MAXIMIZED AND NOT LIMITED BY LOW
QUALITY CD PROGRAMS AND FINALLY.
OUR THIRD POINT IS THAT THESE
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD ENSURE
QUALITY PROGRAMS. ARE SPECIALLY
NECESSARY AND QUALITY ASSURANCE
CONCERNING THAT THERE IS A
CURRENT.
THAT CURRENCY DO PROGRAMS.
.
SHOULD HAVE COME FROM ADHERENCE
TO CT  MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MATT PATTON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE FOCUS
BOTH IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE LEGISLATURE ON CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WE'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THE SELECTION CRITERIA
FOR THOSE CT  PROGRAMS
GETTING FUNDING.
AND ASK FOR ACCOUNTABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE
USED WISELY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
MISTER VOIGHT BALANCE STAFF
THANK YOU FOR STAYING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FIRST LET ME ARE ALIGNED
MYSELF BUT I'M KAI JACKSON
WITHIN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY IN TERMS OF.
CTE FUNDS BEING MORE.
ALIGNED WITH K. TWELVE VICE
THROUGH OTHER CONSORTIUM.
SECONDLY WE APPRECIATE THE
DELIVER A DELIBERATE
CONVERSATION WE HAD HERE TODAY
ABOUT KATE WELL FUNDING AND WE
UNDERSTAND FROM A LOCAL
EDUCATION PERSPECTIVE. THAT
EDUCATION IS A LARGE PORTION OF
THE STATE BUDGET WE TRULY TRULY
APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS BUT WE
WOULD. URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO
HEAVILY ARMED LOOK AT.
REDIRECTING SOME OF THE ONE
TIME FUNDS ARE ONETIME
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INTO OUR OWN
GOING IN THE BASE. TO INCLUDE
ARM SNC DOLLARS
AS APPROPRIATE AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI DENNIE MICHELETTI CULVER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT THE EAST E.
COALITION ARE PROUD MEMBER AND
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
WE'D LIKE TO COME JUST RESPOND
TO A QUESTION THAT YOU HAD ABOUT
WHY THE ONE BILLION FOR BABIES.
SO THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET POLICY
CENTER NOTED THAT THERE WAS ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION INCOME
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN.
THAT DON'T HAVE A SLOT TO GO.
WHEN THE ELIGIBILITY LIST WERE
DISMANTLED IN ROUGHLY TWENTY TEN
TWENTY ELEVEN THERE WAS JUST SHY
OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND.
CHILDREN NEEDING A SLOT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE MEMBERS THINK A
COMING IN AROUND THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND.
I AM. CURRENTLY IN THE THE.
ALTERNATE PAPER PROGRAMS
THERE'S FEWER THAN THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND SLOTS FOR THE WORKING
POOR. AND THOSE ARE THE ONES
THAT NEED THE OFF OUR WEEKEND
CARE THE BILLION FOR BABIES WILL
FUND ROUGHLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL SLOTS.
SO IT MOVES FORWARD TO MAKING AN
INNER OF BUT NO WHERE NEAR
MEETING THE NEEDS.
I'M WE SUPPORT THAT GOVERNOR
CONTINUING TO FUND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR PROVIDERS SO THAT
WHEN RATES WERE BROUGHT UP. NO
PROVIDER RATES WERE GOING TO BE
REDUCED
AND THEN FINALLY WEEKS WE
SUPPORT.
ONE TIME MONIES BEING USED FOR
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM.
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
CONNECT THEM WITH.
OTHER SUPPORTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CITIES ALLEN
DRAVID'S WOULD ASSN PROJECT
CALIFORNIA. OF PART IF THE EASY
COALITION AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE SEQUEL EASY COALITIONS
AND LET'S ITEMS CAUCUS PROPOSAL
FOR BILLION DOLLAR FOR BABIES.
NON DOESN'T IT ONLY SOUND GOOD
BUT IT'S A GREAT POLICY FOR THE
MANY REASONS STATED TODAY. AND
BEFORE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND I THINK I MET TIONNE AARON
THERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU IN
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED
ME.
ASSEMBLYMAN VOEPEL POINT MONEY
TO RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION ALSO
ABOUT WHY BILLION.
I'M DURING THE RECESSION WE LOST
A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS.
BY THIS TIME WE MAYBE HAVE
REPLACED AROUND FORTY FIVE OR
FIFTY THOUSAND OF THEM. RIGHT
THE IS HE COALITION THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS RIGH IN OUR PROPOSALS
OVER THE LAST THREE TO FOUR
YEARS HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT ONE
OF THE ISSUES WE WANTED TO DEAL
WITH WAS RATES. WHICH WE PULL
LEGISLATURE WAS WONDERFUL ABOUT
RIGHT IN CHINA INCREASING RATES
NOT ENOUGH TO OBVIOUSLY ENTERED
INTO IT INTEREST ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO GO INTO THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FIELD. BUT AT LEAST
WE'RE BEGINNING TO TO BILL BE
ABLE TO BUILD BACK UP RIGHT.
BUT THERE WAS A STUDY DONE OF A
BRAND STORY DONE AND I DON'T
CAN'T REMEMBER IF THAT'S
COMMITTEE WAS PART OF THAT
HEARING. WHERE THE BRAND PEOPLE
CAME IN TO TALK ABOUT A NATIONAL
STUDY THAT THEY FOUND THAT WE
NEEDED AROUND A HUNDRED AND
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO DEAL WITH ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY? IF YOU JUST
PRESUME CALIFORNIA'S TEN TEN
PERCENT THAT MEANS THAT IN ORDER
TO FULLY FUND ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
IN THE STATE WE WOULD NEED
AROUND FOURTEEN BILLION.
CURRENTLY THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
AND COMMIT THE BLUE RIBBON I
THANK YOU CAT LIKE COULDN'T
REMEMBER WHERE WE HAD HEARD
THAT.
WHICH WHICH GROUP OF WHEN I AM
NOT IT WAS ONE POINT FOR THEM TO
GO WE CAN DO THAT NOT THAT I
KNOW YOU NEVER YOU MISSPOKE
GIVEN WORK FOURTEEN MILLION.
CURRENTLY WE PUT WE HAVE AROUND
A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION FOR
ELIGIBLE FAMILY SO WE ARE
MISSING AND AROUND TEN. I'M OF
THE IDEA HERE IS OBVIOUSLY IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
BUT A BILLION DOLLARS WOULD TAKE
A SAKE YOU HEARD NUMBERS WISE
WITH A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
PARTICULAR AROUND INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHERE
THE GREATEST NEED IS RIGHT THIS
MOMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT MIGHT CHANGE OVER
THE YEARS. RIGHT AND AND THE
BEAUTY OF THIS IS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN EVERY YEAR TO
LOOK AT WHAT WHERE THE
PRIORITIES BUT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
AROUND INFANTS AND TODDLERS. SO
AS HE ARE YOU IN AND ASKED ME
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PROPOSAL HAS BEEN WE ARE
PART OF THE EASY COALITION.
THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT NAM WHEN I
ASK MY QUESTION I MADE IT VERY
CLEAR IT WAS A FRIENDLY
RESPECTFUL QUESTION.
JUST SO EVERYONE KNOWS ON I'M
ONE OF THE NEWEST MEMBERS ON
THIS COMMITTEE. I REALLY CARE
ABOUT IT.
BUT I DO NOT HAVE ANY BACKGROUND
IN EDUCATION.
OKAY ALMOST VOEPEL AYE I SUGGEST
THAT THAT THE FOLKS HERE FIND
THE PROVIDERS IN YOUR AREA LEMON
GROVE.
WAS THAT IT LIMON GROW NO OKAY
I'M SORRY YOU LOS EAST EASTERN
SAN DIEGO AND WE TAKE MISTER
VOEPEL ON A COUPLE TOURS DURING
THE INTERIM.
HOW ABOUT THAT EXACTLY AYE VOTE
TOURED ALMOST EVERY SCHOOL AT
EVERY LEVEL IN MY DEALT I WANT
TO GO OUT ON A TOUR OF A FAMILY?
DAYCARE CENTER OH I'D LOVE YEAH
AND CENTER BASIC CAN SEE THEM
BOTH INACTION WHAT THE
DIFFERENCES ARE AND WE HAVE A
VERY NOT AND I'D SUPPORT. VERY
STRONGLY ALL PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
SO.
I'M ALSO A FISCAL CONSERVATIVE
SO WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY NATURAL
FOR ME TO ASK.
HOW MUCH MONEY?
SO THANK YOU. GOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE YEAH
GOOD HEARING TODAY WITH THAT WE
ARE ADJOURNED